MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. MCCURRY
ARAMBULA POWER QUE HAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU JUNE
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DE. EGGMAN FLORA PHONE
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA MULLIN
SUSHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE. HE
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. YEAH. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA MR
FLOOR. MEMBERS ABOUT HAD WITH
ME FATHER MAY WE VOTER BLESSING
UPON A LEGISLATORS GATHERED
HERE DIRECTLY DIRECTING THEM TO
ACT JUSTLY LOVE TO NEARLY WHAT
HUMBLY WITH OUR GOD AS A
REPRESENT THE ASPIRATIONS OF
THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA IN YOUR
NAME WE PRAY. AMEN. THANK YOU
MISS FOR WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN DOCTOR WOULD AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. A. IS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO FRIDAY MAY TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY RECENTLY
MET AT SIX AM THE AUDIBLE
JACQUI IRWIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FORTY FOUR DISTURBANCE IDC
PARKS YOU PARKER MODESTO SYSTEM
FOR DAVID GOING READING ROLL
CALL THE FOLLOWING WORKPLACE ON
THE MORNING ROLL CALL
AGUIAR-CURRY AROUND OKAY HAND
BURKE BLOOM THE WHOLE ROUTE TO
BROKE PER. NIELSEN CHAU. SHORT
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP. FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA. GONZALEZ GREG
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES-SAWYER CALL KAMLAGER LACKEY
LEVINE. LIMON LOW MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK SILVA
RONALD'S REYES THREE OF US
MEMBER RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SANTIAGO SMITH PHONE TING.
VOEPEL WEBER WOULDN'T. ONE
PRESIDENT TEN AM YEAH. WEBER
SEVEN THIS PROVIDE RENTAL
BUSINESS DISPENSED WITH BY
CONSENT. SOME WAS DISPENSED
WITH FULLER DAY LEAVES ABOUT
WITH A BY MANSON IS. AND GAVE.
MOVE AND MISTER FLORA SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
TO WITH THE WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JAMES RAMOS AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TYLER DEEP. FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER.
FOR MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE RUN A AND SALAS.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT. PROCEDURAL
YEAH. MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENSUS
EMILY TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN TO HAVE
GUESTS SEATED AFTER DEATH.
WITHOUT A GAY. SHALL BE THE
ORDER. IN SENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
A MEMORY. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION. TO BE THE ORDER I'M
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS OF
INACTIVE FILE ITEM ME TOO AS
BEFORE SENDING AYE ATKINS AT
THE REQUEST OF THIS OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA. AND I TO ME NINE
SB THREE TO. WIRE AT THE
REQUEST OF A MEMBER. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. MOVES TO SPEND A
RULE NINETY SO. AND ASSEMBLY
RULES SIXTY THREE TO WITH. AS
THREE HUNDRED NUMBER FROM THE
LOW TO AND READ. CAN TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN TO TAKE
UP THE BILL TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING. MR
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WITHHOLDING ASK
CONSENT AFTER ROLL CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA WITHHOLDS MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR BONTA
SECONDS ON THE RULES SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. PARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR
A NO MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. MR FLOORS AS FOR NO.
QUIRK WELL. CLOSER ROLE TIDE
ABOUT ICE WOULD FIVE NO FORTY
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED. MISTER
CALDERON CURING I RECOGNIZE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX A REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE SB WANTED THE IT
ALLEN AND SB TWO SEVENTEEN
PORTANTINO FROM THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE. AT THE FROM THE A
EDUCATION COMMITTEE SB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE PAN FROM THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE SB THREE FIFTEEN
HERTZBERG FROM THE REVENUE TAX
COMMITTEE SB THREE SIXTY NINE
HERTZBERG FROM TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE S. BEFORE SEVENTY
FOUR STERN FROM THE WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE SB SIX
TWENTY NINE REQUIRE FROM THE
NATURAL COMMITTEE S. SEVENTY
I'M PORTANTINO FROM THE EDGE
COMMITTEE AND SCA. GALS FROM
ELECTION AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT A- SUCH A BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
WILL SEVENTY SEVEN ALLOW SOME
MEMBER TING TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BUDGET RELATED BILLS
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONCURRENT THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS AND OTHER ITEMS FOUR
THROUGH TWENTY TWO. AB.
787-981-8080 288-909-2931
HUNDRED ONE OF 275-131-1980
THREE EIGHTY FOUR AND EIGHTY
NINE. MR FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR
THE WAS SPEAKER WE HAVE WITH
HOLD ELSE CAN. NATURAL CALL THE-
MR FLORA HOLES. THIS CALL MOVES
AND MISS BONTA SET. MEMBERS
THIS A PROCEDURE THOUGH. CLERK
WILL THE ROLE. THIS CALL TASK
FOR AND I'VE ON THE RULE SYSTEM.
MR FLORA NO MISTER CALDERON IS
ASK FOR AN I. VOTE AND FLORES
FOR A NO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL TITLE BUT I FIFTIES
KNOWS FIFTY THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED MISTER CALDERON YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN TO
TAKE UP A CA FOR AN ACA SEVEN
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
CONCURRENT AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YEAH.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
BE TAKING UP A NUMBER OF BUDGET
ITEMS AT THIS TIME. WE ARE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO. AT. FIVE
TWENTY TWO. AB EIGHTY NINE.
LOCAL RATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AN
ACT RELATING TO THE STATE
BUDGET MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUDGET BILL MR TAKE
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM HER PRESENT AB
EIGHT NINE WE WERE HERE A WEEK
AND A HALF AGO PASSED IN OUR
BUDGET BILL. THAT BILL JUST
REMIND EVERYBODY FOCUSED ON
ENSURING THAT IN TIMES OF
UNCERTAINTY THE WE WERE THERE
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS ARE THE
MOST CRITICAL SERVICES WHETHER
IT WAS EDUCATION WITH
HEALTHCARE WEATHER'S HUMAN
SERVICES. IF THAT IN TIME SPEND
THAT MAKE. THE WE DIDN'T TURN
BACKS ON THE- NOW WITH HAVE
MADE MORE CALL. IT HAVE A BOAT.
THAT WAS BETTER FOR OUR BALL
RATING WE DECIDED THAT IT WAS
MORE. TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOL.
REMAIN HELD HER. USE MORE POOR
TO MAKE WE DIDN'T CUT
HEALTHCARE OR TOUCH ALL THE FOR
THE WITH PROP FIFTY SIX WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE WITH COLORFUL
SAFETY FOR PEOPLE WHO WE NEED
FOOD WHO NEED CRITICAL SERVICES
AT THIS. SO THERE ARE A COUPLE
DO. NOW BECAUSE TODAY WE HAVE
AGREE WITH THE GUY. AND SO THE
MAIN DIFFERENCE THIS BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR IS HOW WE DEALT
WITH OUR TRIGGER. YOU MIGHT
RECALL WE HAD A FEDERAL TRIGGER
ASSUMING BUT THE FEDERAL MONEY
WAS GOING TO COME AND IF IT
DIDN'T COME. THE WE'D HAVE TO
DO CUTS. SO WE DON'T DO ANY A
SOME SHOWN AROUND FEDERAL
FUNDING IN TERMS OF THE MONEY
BEING HERE. WHAT IT SAYS IS.
THE BUDGET WILL INCREASE ON
OCTOBER FIFTEENTH IF WE GET THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND IT WILL
INCREASE TO REDUCE THE PROPERTY
TO FOR ALL FOR THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE BORROWING FOR SCHOOLS.
YOU SEE AND SEE IF YOU'LL GO 5%
MORE. FOR ANOTHER HUNDRED AND-
MILLION. IT WILL OFFSET THE
ALMOST THREE BILLION IN STATE
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION CUTS THAT
THEY TOOK AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE WHETHER TAKING AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE A RESTORED
MODERNA CAN HOUSING FUNDING AN
INFILL GRANTS IT ALSO RETAINS
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
PROGRAM PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION MORNING COUNTY
REALIGNMENT BACK FILL FOR A
TOTAL OF ONE BILLION TO THE
COUNTIES. THAT ALSO FUNDS LOCAL
CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES. AGAIN
THIS BUDGET WE COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING THAT WAS BETTER FOR
WALL STREET BUTIN THE END WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MONEY GOT TO MAIN STREET SO
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHANG MISTER
OBERNOLTE OR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER A COLLEAGUES
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
BUDGET WE'RE CONSIDERING TODAY
IS SLIGHTLY. MORE FISCALLY
CONSERVATIVE THAN THE ONE WE
PASSED LAST WEEK. THE BAD NEWS
IS THAT THIS BUDGET IS STILL
STRUCTURALLY YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE. THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DEAL WITH ON MAIN
STREET AS WELL AS WALL STREET
IN THE FUTURE. THE BUDGET WERE
VOTING ON TODAY BALANCES
REVENUES WITH EXPENDITURE NOT
THROUGH REDUCTIONS IN STATE
SPENDING BUT INSTEAD. THROUGH A
COMBINATION OF BUDGETARY
GIMMICKS. SUCH AS DEFERRALS.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF INTER
FUND TRANSFERS AND LOANS AND
THE DEPLETION OF OVER HALF OF
OUR STATES BUDGETARY RESERVES.
I KNOW THE CUTS ARE PAINFUL TO
MAKE. BUT OUR FAILURE TO MAKE
THOSE DIFFICULT DECISIONS THIS
YEAR OR IS GOING TO HAVE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES FOR US. IN FUTURE
YEARS. AND I FEAR THAT THE
BUDGET THAT WERE PASSING TODAY
IS GOING TO MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT. TO BALANCE BUDGETS
AND AVOID CUTS IN THE FUTURE I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
REALTY MR FALL IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BUDGET NO MATTER HOW YOU
DRESS UP THIS BUDGET WITH
RHETORIC THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE
IS A FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED
BUDGET. IS A BUDGET THAT
BECAUSE FOR MORE BORROWING MORE
DEFERRALS REALIZE AN ACCOUNTING
GIMMICKS AND HOPES AND WISHES
FOR THINGS TO COME THAT MAY NOT
HAPPEN. IT'S HOPING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME AND BAIL
US OUT IT WHICH IS A BETTER
ECONOMIC FORECAST NUMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE MUCH MORE POSITIVE
THAN WHAT WAS PRESENTED TO US
THERE IS NO WAY TO RESPONSIBLY
MANAGE OUR STATE THAT THIS IS
NO WAY TO RESPOND TO MANAGE OUR
STATE BUDGET. THIS BUDGET IS
NOT MAKING THE TOUGH CHOICES WE
ALL KNOW WE NEED NEED TO NEED
TO BE MADE THE FACT THAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL FUNDING IS STILL
HAPPENING IN THIS BUDGET SHOULD
BE DISCONCERTING TO EVERY
TAXPAYER IN THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CUTS THAT
ARE BEING PROPOSED TO OTHER
NECESSARY PROGRAMS THE PUBLIC
RIGHTFULLY EXPECTS AND DEMANDS
FOR US TO BE GOOD STEWARDS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IT'S MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY GIVEN OUR CURRENT
BUDGET. YEAH THIS BUDGET. DOES
THE OPPOSITE. IT CONTINUES TO
FIND WAY FOR PRO. THERE ARE
OVER FOR TO MAKE GOVERNMENT
MORE EFFICIENT AND IT INCLUDES.
A BILLION TAX. WHY ARE WE
RAISING TAXES DURING A TIME
WHEN BUSINESSES AND FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY TO
SURVIVE. THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT THIS BUDGET DOES NOT MEET
THE MOMENT THAT IS REQUIRED.
THIS BUDGET ONLY DELAYS THE
INEVITABLE YOU WILL HAVE TO
COME BACK AGAIN TO PLUG ANOTHER
BUDGET DEFICIT BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T DO WHAT WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO. FOR THESE REASONS I
OPPOSE THIS BUDGET BECAUSE IT
IS NOT BALLOTS IT IS NOT
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH
FALLS SHORT OF WHAT TAXPAYERS
EXPECTS OF US. MR LEVINE. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO OUR BUDGET CHAIR AS WELL AS
THE LEGISLATIVE LEADERS FOR THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE PUTIN TO
GETTING TO THIS BUDGET ON JUNE.
TWENTY SIX. IT WAS JUST A MONTH
AGO ON MAY TWENTY SIX DURING
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE. THEN I
RAISED ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUES FACING OUR
STATE WHICH IS THE RISING SURGE
OF CODED NINETEEN INFECTIONS IN
OUR PRISONS. WHEN I SPOKE ON
MAY TWENTY SIX THERE WERE NINE
HUNDRED STATEWIDE INFECTIONS.
ZERO AT SAN QUENTIN STATE
PRISON BUT TODAY WHEN I SPEAK
TO YOU THERE ARE. FOUR THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
INFECTIONS. AND FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT POSITIVES AT
SAN QUENTIN. WHEN I ROSE ON MAY
TWENTY SIX. I ASKED THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FOR A PLAN
HOW WILL OUR PRISONS PLAN FOR
RESEARCH HOW WILL THEY PLAN FOR
AN OUTBREAK HOW WILL THEY PLAN
FOR THE NEED FOR
HOSPITALIZATION. FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE SICK AND INFECTED WITH CODE
NINETEEN. IT'S NOW JUNE TWENTY
SIX AND THERE IS NO PLAN. THERE
IS NO PLAN AT ALL THERE IS NO
TESTING SYSTEM FOR ANY STAFF AT
SAN QUENTIN RIGHT NOW A JUDGE
HAD TO ROLL THAT THEY MUST TEST
THE STAFF. BUT THERE IS NO
ONGOING TEST FOR STAFF TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT BRINGING
CODED IN. AND THERE IS NO PLAN
FOR HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INMATES THE PRISONERS AT SAN
QUENTIN ARE PROTECTED OR
ANYWHERE ELSE IN PRISON
FACILITIES. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. NOW I HAVE BEEN ASSURED
AGAIN I ASKED A MONTH AGO AT
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE FOR A
PLAN AND A PLAN FOR
HOSPITALIZATION I'VE BEEN
ASSURED. BY THE GOVERNOR STAFF.
THAT I WILL BE RECEIVING A
DETAILED PLAN BUT MY COMMUNITY
IS WAITING. MY HOSPITALS ARE
CONCERNED THEY SEE THE RISING
RATES OF INFECTION ACROSS THE
STATE IN IN OUR COMMUNITY THERE
IS COMMUNITY SPREAD. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE NEED TO
PLAN FOR THOSE RISING NEEDS FOR
HOSPITALIZATION AND I SEE USE
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE.
AN UNCONTROLLABLE OUTBREAK IN
OUR PRISONS THAT WILL OVERWHELM
LOCAL HOSPITAL CAPACITY IN MANY
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. WE ARE
WAITING FOR THE PLAN I ASKED
FOR ON MAY TWENTY SIX IT'S JUNE
TWENTY SIX TODAY. YESTERDAY
DURING A CALL WITH OUR BUDGET
CHAIR AND OUR SUB BUDGET CHAIR
ON PUBLIC SAFETY. WE SPOKE WITH
THE FEDERAL RECEIVER. WHERE HE
ADMITTED HIS CULPABILITY. HIS
MISTAKE HE USED THE WORD
MISTAKE IN ORDERING THE
TRANSFER OF PRISONERS FROM
CHINO TO SAN QUENTIN. AND I AM
CALLING ON JUDGE T<c.cyan> GAR TO</c>
RELIEVE THE FEDERAL RECEIVER
CLARK KELSO OF HIS DUTIES AS A
RECEIVER AND TO REPLACE THAT
PERSON WITH SOMEONE WHO CAN
MORE COMPETENTLY MAKE SURE THAT
OUR PRISONERS ARE RECEIVING
ADEQUATE CARE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER LEVINE. MR KILEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT TODAY WERE
COMPLETING WHAT WILL SURELY GO
DOWN AS THE LEAST TRANSPARENT
BUDGET PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. CALIFORNIA HAS A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY LEGISLATORS
AND FORTY MILLION PEOPLE AND
THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY COMES
FROM BY THE WAY IT'S THEIR- BUT
UP UNTIL A FEW DAYS AGO THE
CONTENTS OF THIS BUDGET WERE-
KNOWN. TO ALL BUT A FEW PEOPLE.
WHAT HAPPENS IN HERE. IS
BECOMING MORE AND MORE OF A
FORMALITY. AND I KNOW SOME WILL
SAY THIS IS JUST BECAUSE OF
COVERT NINETEEN. BUT IT'S
AWFULLY CONVENIENT. THAT TE
DISTORTIONS TO THE PROCESS AND
MADE IN THE NAME OF COVERT.
HAVE SERVED TO EXTEND TRENDS
THAT ARE YEARS IN THE MAKING.
DOING MORE AND MORE OF THE
PUBLIC'S BUSINESS OUTSIDE THE
PUBLIC'S. USING BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS FOR LEGISLATION RATHER
THAN IMPLMENTATION SHUTTING
OUT AND ALL TOO OFTEN SHUTTING
DOWN GROUPS THAT LACK POLITICAL
POWER. BUT WHAT CONCERNS ME
MOST IS THE PRESIDENT. BECAUSE
IN RECENT YEARS EVERY STEP
WE'VE TAKEN DOWN THE LADDER OF
TRANSPARENCY HAS BROUGHT US
WITHIN REACH OF THE NEXT WRONG
HELLO WHEN I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN NOW THAT
WE FALLING OFF THE LADDER
ALTOGETHER. DR ARAMBULA YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY NINE AND
ALL OF THE HARD WORK THAT HAS
GONE INTO PREPARING AND
PRESERVING THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE FAMILIES RELY ON THE MOST
AB EIGHTY NINE ACKNOWLEDGES THE
REALITIES THAT ARE FAMILIES
FACE AT THIS TIME. I'M GLAD
THAT THIS BILL WE ARE
PRESERVING SO MUCH OF THE
PROGRESS THAT WE HAVE MADE IN
OUR RECENT YEARS THROUGH
BENEFITS THAT I BELIEVE SHOULD
BE ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL WHETHER
THEY ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH OUR
HEALTH CARE FOR HUMAN SERVICES
SYSTEMS. PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
SUPPORTED IN MAYBE EIGHTY NINE
HERE TODAY OUR PROGRAM SUCH AS
THE MEDICARE ALL ADULTS AND
DENTAL OPTIONAL BENEFITS AND
DIABETES. PREVENTION PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SO CRITICAL FOR
PREVENTATIVE HEALTH. FOR THE
SEA BASS EMESIS PETE AND THE
MEALS ON WHEELS THAT HELP OUR
SENIORS BE HEALTHY AND SAFE IN
THE COMFORT OF THEIR OWN HOMES.
TO THE AGED AND DISABLED
PROGRAM THAT HELPS THE POOREST
OF THE POOR MAKE ENDS MEET. TO
CAL WORKS THAT HELPS PUT
FAMILIES BACK TO WORK TO THE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE TO HELP
OUR YOUNG ADULTS WHO HAVE HAD
SO MUCH DISRUPTION IN THEIR
LIVES. THROUGH NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. TO OUR DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT HELP
CREATE DIGNITY AND EQUITY FOR
ARE DEPENDENT ADULTS. AND MANY
OTHERS THAT WILL HELP OUR
COUNTIES BEAR THE FINANCIAL
COST OF THIS PANDEMIC. I KNOW
THAT OUR WORK IS NOT OVER. BUT
I ALSO KNOW THAT THIS BUDGET
AGREEMENT INVEST IN OUR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES AND
WILL HELP CARRY US THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC AND HELP US TO GET
BACK ON YOUR FEET. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE TODAY. THEY GET A
CURRICULA LIKE ANY RECOGNIZE ON
THE ADAM PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES AT THIS TIME MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS- I RISE IN OPPOSITION
DAVEY EIGHTY NINE. AND ONE OF
THE PROVISIONS IN HERE THAT I.
RELEASED STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER. IN LAYING OFF THIS
BILL AT THE VERY LEAST IS A
PROVISION THAT GIVES THE
GOVERNOR AND THE ADMINISTRATION
TOTAL DISCRETION. OVER MONIES.
DESIGNED TO HELP YOUR COUNTIES
RECOVER FROM COVE IN NINETEEN
NOW THIS IS UP ALMOST UPWARDS
OF A BILLION DOLLARS OF FEDERAL
CARES MONEY. THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO GO TO
YOUR COUNTIES. TO THE PEOPLE
YOU REPRESENT WHO WHO ALL OF US
EVERY COUNTY WAS ON TOUCH WAS
EVERY COUNTY WAS TOUCHED BY
COVERT NINETEEN IN SOME WAY
EVERY BUSINESS. IN YOUR
DISTRICT WAS TOUCHED IN SOME
WAY BY COVERT NINETEEN UP
UPWARDS OF A BILLION DOLLARS OF
FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S COMING TO
HELP YOUR COUNTIES. IS SUBJECT
ON THE WHIM OF THE GOVERNOR. TO
BE WITHHELD. SALES TAX MONIES
IT'S COMING BACK INTO HELP
REIMBURSED YOUR COUNTIES- TO
MAKE UP THAT BACK FILL OF SALES
TAX MONIES LOST DURING COVERED
NINETEEN IS SUBJECT TO THE WHIM
OF THE GOVERNOR. AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT THAT MONEY WILL ACTUALLY
GO. IN INSTEAD OF US BEING IN
CONTROL THE LEGISLATURE WHO
CONTROLS THE PURSE. INSTEAD OF
US BEING A CONTROL INSANE THIS
MONEY IS DESIGNED TO BE FOR
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA. A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL AS THE
GOVERNOR TALKS ABOUT. IS
SUPPOSED TO GO TO ALL OF US
BECAUSE WE'VE ALL BEEN IMPACTED.
NOW SOME OF OU MIGHT SAY WELL
I TRUST THE GOVERNOR. HE'LL
MAKE GOOD DECISIONS HE WILL
HELP YOU WOULDN'T DO THAT TO MY
AREA. AND LET ME JUST GIVE YOU
EXHIBIT DAY BECAUSE I'VE GONE
THROUGH THIS ALREADY IN MY
DISTRICT AND I WANT YOU TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THIS. THE
YUBA SUTTER REGION. OPENED UP
EARLY AND THAT'S WHAT YOU HEARD
IN THE MEDIA. BUT WHAT YOU
DIDN'T HEAR. AND WHAT NOBODY
REALLY TALKED ABOUT AS A THAT
WAS OPENED NOT BY PEOPLE JUST
MOVING FORWARD AND SAYING WE'RE
GONNA OPEN IT WAS OPENED BY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER. A
MINORITY WOMAN DOCTOR JOHN
HOPKINS EDUCATED DOCTOR. WHO
MADE THE DECISION TO OPEN BASED
ON JOHN HOPKINS SAFETY
PROTOCOLS THE SAME ONES THAT
THE GOVERNOR SAID THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO FOLLOW. AND HOW
WAS. MY COUNTY TREATED MY
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER TREATED
BY THIS GOVERNOR. SHE WAS
DENIGRATED AS SAYING SHE'S
RECKLESS AND SHE IS DANGEROUS.
AND WHEN OUR BUSINESSES OPEN
UNDER THAT SAFETY PROTOCOL THAT
INCLUDED MASKS THAT INCLUDED
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE WILL BE
DISTANCED THAT INCLUDED ALL
THESE SOCIAL AT ALL THE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS. THE GOVERNOR SENT
OUT AGENTS ABC AGENTS AND
OTHERS TO PENALIZE THESE
BUSINESSES. MANY OF THEM
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES AND
RESTAURANTS. THE PEOPLE ARE
ALREADY BEEN THROUGH ALL THE
HELL THAT CAME WITH COVERT
NINETEEN OF HAVING TO BE SHUT
DOWN. AND BEING ON THE VERGE OF
BANKRUPTCY ONLY HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT COME IN AND SAY
WE'RE GOING TO SHUT YOU DOWN
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
FIND YOU. WE'RE GONNA SUBJECTED
TO PROBATION THAT'S HOW THIS
GOVERNOR EXERCISED. HIS
AUTHORITY AGAINST MY COUNTIES.
ONE WOMAN BUSINESS OWNER
WAILING BASICALLY ON THE VERGE
OF SUICIDE. WARNING THAT SHE
WAS GONNA HAVE AN A. B. C.
AGENT CLOSER BUSINESS DOWN AND
SHE WAS GOING TO BE OUT OF
BUSINESS FOREVER. THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED WHEN THIS GOVERNOR GOT
TOTAL DISCRETION ABOUT. AND
THAT'S NOT EVEN THE END CAUSE
ANY THREATEN MY COUNTY TO TAKE
AWAY EMERGENCY FUNDS FEDERAL
EMERGENCY FUNDS. FROM MARK
COUNTIES. BECAUSE IN HIS SOLE
DISCRETION WE WEREN'T ACTING
SAFELY EVEN THOUGH WE WERE
OPERATING ACCORDING TO THE
ORDER OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER. IN ACCORDANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL. SAFETY
COMPLIANCE DOCTRINES. AND YOU
MIGHT SAY WELL THAT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN IN MY COUNTY. THE MAN
LAST WEEK I HEARD I HEARD A LOT
OF A SCENE INJUSTICE ANYWHERE.
IS A THREAT TO JUSTICE
EVERYWHERE. AND BY THE WAY
WE'RE THE ONES WHO ARE IN
CONTROL OF THE PURSE WHY ARE WE
ALLOWING HIM TO DECIDE. WHETHER
OR NOT WE GET RELIEF THAT WERE
ALREADY ENTITLED TO. THAT ARE
COUNTIES IN OUR BUSINESSES AND
OUR PEOPLE ARE ALREADY ENTITLED
TO. PLEASE DON'T DO THIS.
THIRTY SECONDS. THERE IS
ALREADY MENTIONED AGAIN WORD
THIS LANGUAGE COME FROM IT
WASN'T DEBATED HERE. IT WASN'T
DEBATED IN THE SUB COMMITTEES
ABOUT HAVING THIS AS A
REQUIREMENT. IT WAS IN SECRET
DEALINGS THAT ARE NOW ONLY
COMING TO LIGHT AND YOU GOT A
VOTE ON YOU GOT TO VOTE YES OR
NO. LET'S HOLD THE LINE AND SAY
NO GOVERNOR. NO WE'RE NOT GONNA
LET YOU A LOT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO ALLOW YOU TO ACT JUSTLY.
TOWARDS OUR COMMUNITIES. IF
YOU'RE AN ORANGE COUNTY YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED TO YOU.
PLEASE GOD DON'T THINK IT WON'T
HAPPEN AGAIN. PLEASE VOTE NO OR
LAY OFF OF THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. THERE WAS GALLAGHER
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I AM.
WAS PREPARED FOR MUST WORK MUCH
WORSE BUDGET THEN WHAT IS PRINT
BEING PRESENTED TODAY. I WAS
PREPARING. MY CONSTITUENTS MY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN PARTICULAR.
FOR A MUCH WORSE BUDGET. YEAH
REMINDING THEM THAT WE ARE
GOING THROUGH THE WORST
RECESSION SINCE PERHAPS THE
GREAT DEPRESSION. AND SO WHEN I
WAS CHECKING IN WITH MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THIS PAST WEEK THEIR
RESPONSE IS ALMOST UNIFORM IT
COULD HAVE BEEN A LOT WORSE.
AND SO. I APPRECIATE OUR BUDGET
CHAIR IN APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE FOR
REACHING THIS DEAL THAT. STAYS
OFF MANY OF THE PAINFUL THE
MOST PAINFUL CUTS. THAT THE- WE
COULD HAVE BEEN FACING A GIVEN
THAT WE ARE GOING THROUGH
PERHAPS THE WORST RECESSION
SINCE THE GREAT DEPRESSION. SO
I WANTED TO FIRST- GOT
HIGHLIGHT MY APPRECIATION FOR
THAT BUT IT GOING FORWARD. AND
I THINK THERE ISSUES NOT ONLY
IN THIS BUDGET BELL BUT ALSO IN
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE BUDGET
TRAILER THAT I'LL BE ADDRESSING
LATER. BUT THERE IS THE ONGOING
ISSUE ABOUT WHETHER ALL OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE RECIEVING
THE BASIC FUNDING THAT THEY
NEED TO BE PREPARED TO CONTINUE
TO DEAL WITH THIS COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. I UNDERSTAND
WHY THE GOVERNOR FOUGHT ROLE
HARD TO DEVOTE THE OVERWHELMING.
BALK OF THE FEDERAL CARES ACT
DOLLARS TO THE HIGH POVERTY
DISTRICTS THAT ARE
DEMONSTRATING THE BIGGEST
LEARNING LOSSES IN THIS AGE OF
COVERT NINETEEN AND IN THIS AGE
OF DISTANCE LEARNING. BUT I
ASKED THE LA- FOR SOME
BREAKDOWNS IN TERMS OF. YOU
KNOW WHAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
RECEIVING ON A PER PUPIL BASIS.
IN THE NAME OF EQUITY. AND SO
YOU KNOW AS AN EXAMPLE I
REPRESENT. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
REPORTS OF A PORTION OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED AS WELL AS THE
HERMOSA BEACH ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT FROM ONE FROM THE EAST
END OF MY DISTRICT TO THE WEST
AND ON THE COAST. THE OTHER END
OF MY DISTRICT. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED ON A PER PEOPLE BASIS
IS GOING TO BE RECEIVING UNDER
THIS FINAL BUDGET DEAL. FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER STUDENT. HER
MOST TO BEACH SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS GO GOING TO BE RECEIVING.
NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE DOLLARS AND PER
PEOPLE SPENDING. MORE THAN A
SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR GAP FOR
EACH KID WHETHER YOU'RE IN LA
UNIFIED OR WHETHER YOU IN
HERMOSA BEACH UNIFIED. NOW
AGAIN YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT- HERMOSA. IS. MORE
AFFLUENT THAN MOST OF THE LAUSD
NEIGHBORHOODS. BUT SIX THOUSAND
DOLLAR GAP A SIX THOUSAND
DOLLAR DEFICIT AT SOME POINT I
CANNOT SUPPORT A BUDGET THAT
DOESN'T GIVE THE BASIC FUNDING
TO ALL OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE IN THIS
COVER NINETEEN REALITY. THE
ONLY REASSURED THIS MORNING
FROM THE LA THAT. UNDER THIS
DEAL. THAT ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING HERMOSA BEACH UNIFIED
WILL BE GETTING. MORE THAN THEY
ARE RECEIVING IN THIS CURRENT
SCHOOL THE IN THIS CURRENT
SCHOOL YEAR YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
MUCH IS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS MORE FOR. HERMOSA AND-
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
MORE PER STUDENT FOR LA UNIFIED.
AGAIN YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE GREATEST. YOU KNOW
RESOURCES TO GO TO VEGAS TO THE
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST
NEEDS. BUT LET'S NOT KEEP IN
MIND THAT WE NEED TO HAVE THE
BASIC FUNDING THE BASIC GRANT
ISSUE OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE BASIC ADEQUACY OF
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO
THAT ALL OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. CAN CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE OUR KIDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OUT I'LL TALK LATER ON
THE EDUCATION TRAILER BILL THE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM. SOUTH LA
MENTION BUT THE BIG PICTURE ON
THIS BUDGET IS- WE HAD TO
BRIDGE TWO VERSIONS THE
GOVERNOR'S NAVY REVISE WHICH
WOULD HAVE BEEN A DISASTER FOR
US THREE OPENING OUR STATE
TURNING BACK ON THE LIGHTS
WHICH ARE ECONOMY. PROPERLY
FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS CHILD CARE
CENTERS BECAUSE OF THOSE TWO
THINGS AREN'T WORKING PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO WORK
AND I LIKE TO KNOW THAT ARE
SPEAKER BUDGET SHARE THE PRO
TâM AND BUDGET CHAIR DID A
GREAT JOB AGO SHADING AND THIS
IS. A GOOD DEAL OF CALIPH
SCHOOLS AND FIRST. HEATHER
BUDGETS NOTED THIS IS AGAIN TO
GET A PLAQUE AWAY. FROM OUR FOR
BOND. NOR IS GOING TO US IN THE
PAST AND BACK FROM THE-
AUSTERITY GROUP THAT WANTS TO
JUDGES FROM THE TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. BUT OUR JOB IS TO
FOCUS ON OUR COMMUNITIES BACK
HOME OUR SCHOOLS ARE COLLEGES
OR UNIVERSITIES. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE HOW SYSTEM.
MR BUT- GLOW. CRY AND PAN. AND
THE CHOICES WE HAVE TO MAKEHERE.ARE NOT PERFECT EVERY
BUDGET HAS BLOCKS EVERY BUDGET
IS YOU KNOW PORTS AND PICK. ONE
HAS QUITE A FEW BUT ARE TWO. IS
WHAT IS VERY VERY STE I GREW.
AND SO THIS PLACE. PLAN FOR ALL
OF. IT'S GOOD DIFFICULT NOW
YEAR AS AS WE AS WELL. BUT THIS
ALLOWS US TO READ NON SIR. CAL.
BACK TO. MOST POORLY OPEN PART.
SYSTEM EDUCATE THROUGH THIS
WITH LAST BY THE- THANK YOU
MISTER MAKER. THANK YOU MEMBER.
MR. MS REYES IS MAKING HER WAY
TO THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER MS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RISING URGENT AYE VOTE ON
EIGHTY EIGHTY NINE. WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE'RE LIVING IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES AND IN
THESE TIMES IT REQUIRES ACTION.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BUDGET
REPRESENTS. A CALL TO ACTION TO
RESPOND TO ONE OF THE MOST
DEVASTATING ADVANCE TO FACE
AREN'T STATE AND OUR NATION.
IT'S FUN OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE FACED THIS BUDGET
PROTECTS. VITAL SERVICES FROM
DEVASTATING CUTS AND MAKES
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FUTURE.
SPECIFICALLY TO ASSIST OUR
WORKING FAMILIES. AS A STATE
WITNESS IN BUDGETS FROM DECADES
AGO. FAILING TO PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE HAS LONG TERM
COSTS THAT IN MANY CASES WE ARE
STILL ADDRESSING TO THIS DAY.
THAT IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT TO
PASS THIS BUDGET THAT MAKES
RESPONSIBLE CHOICES WITHOUT
PLACING THE BURDEN OF THOSE
CHOICES ON THOSE THAT CAN LEAST
AFFORD IT. AS LEGISLATORS. WE
HAVE A DUTY TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES THIS BUDGET
PROTECTS CORE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS PROTECTS CHILD CARE
FUNDING RATES AND PROTECTS KEY
HEALTH AND SENIOR PROGRAMS AND
IT DOES SO ONE AWAY THE DOES
NOT ASSUME FEDERAL FUNDING. WE
NEED TO REBUILD OUR ECONOMY
PROTECT JOBS AND GIVE OUR
COMMUNITIES HOPE. AND LET'S NOT
FORGET AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO SHARED. THE SENATE
THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUED THE
HARD DISCUSSIONS AFTER OUR VOTE
LAST WEEK TO MAKE SURE THAT
TODAY'S. BUDGET REPRESENTED A
BETTER PROPOSAL FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. ONE LAST POINT
IS SOMETHING THAT IS A VERY KEY
IN THIS IS THAT IT DID SHORES
THAT NO CHILDREN ARE CUT FROM
EXISTING CARE PROGRAMS IT
PROTECTS CHILD CARE FUNDING
RATES AND INCREASES CHILD CARE
ACCES FOR CENTRAL WORKERS. WE
TALK AND WE TALK ABOUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT AND HERE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THE
BUDGET THAT IS GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF THE VERY PEOPLE WE HAVE
SAID WE WERE GOING TO PROTECT.
THIS IS THE BUDGET THE
REPRESENTS A COMPROMISE THESE
ARE DIFFICULT TIMES. NOBODY
WANTS TO VOTE ON THIS BILL IT'S
CLEAR FROM SOME OF WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING. BUT WE HAVE TO VOTE ON
A BILL THAT IS GOING TO PROTECT
THE VERYPEOPLE WE SAID. WHEN
WE RAN FOR OFFICE THE VERY
PEOPLE WE SAID WE WERE GOING TO
PROTECT. IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS I URGE AN AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU MISS REST.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR
THE SENATE AND OUR HOUSE FIRST
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PUBLICLY THANK THE SENATE
AND THE SENATE PRO TEM IN
PARTICULAR. FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP AND FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP TOGETHER THE
LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED HARD TO
PROTECT AND MAINTAIN THE
PROGRAMS THAT MEANS SO MUCH TO
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS THAT
INCLUDES PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND IT MEANS OUR
SENIORS AMONG OTHERS. THERE
NEEDS HAVE INCREASED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC WE HAVE NOT
FORGOTTEN THEM WE OF COURSE
MUST ALSO THINK THE GOVERNOR
FOR HIS AGREEMENT ON IMPORTANT
ISSUES LIKE THIS EXPANSION OF
CALLIE ITC TO INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
FILERS WITH CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF SIX PREVENTING LAYOFFS
IN SCHOOLS AND WORKING TOWARD
FALL. WAS AWESOME THANK. THE
COLLABORATION BY THE- THIS KEY
BECAUSE EDUCATION IS THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR ATTEMPTS TO
KEEP CALIFORNIA GROWING. THIS
BUDGET RECOGNIZES THAT. I WANT
TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE STATE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY WERE KEY
IN BUDGET DISCUSSIONS. THEY
MADE SACRIFICES AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE EVEN AS THEY
ARE DOING THE HARD WORK TO
ASSIST RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES. DEAL WITH THE
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS
WE ARE GOING THROUGH. AS I SAID
LAST TIME WE MET WE MET THERE
IS MORE TO BE DONE. WE MUST
URGE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
DEVELOP MEANINGFUL AID FOR
STATE AND LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT NEEDED PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAMS TO BOOST THE ECONOMY
AND TO HELP RESTORE FUNDING TO
ARE PRIZED UNIVERSITIES. TO OUR
HOUSING PROGRAMS AND TO OTHER
TASKS THAT WE HAVE BEFORE US.
LASTLY BUT ABOVE ALL I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THIS
HOUSE. FOR THEIR HARD WORK WITH
PARTICULAR THANKS TO THE HARD
WORK OF THE KEY PLAYERS ON OUR
BUDGET TEAM. THIS IS GIVEN AS A
BUDGET THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE IMPORTANT SUPPORT. FOR
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS AT A
DIFFICULT TIME. OUR BUDGET IS
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT WILL
GUIDE US THROUGH THE COMING
MONTHS AND THE COMING
DIFFICULTIES CONGRATULATIONS ON
WHAT YOU'VE DONE. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. WITH
THAT QUIRK THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. OF ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO
SIXTEEN. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. AB SEVENTY EIGHT.
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND OTHERS AND I
RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET MR TANG IMAGEN OFTEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
SEVENTY AUTHORIZES I BY. TO
ESTABLISH ONE OR MORE PROGRAM
AS- BY THE BANK DIRECT TO SEE.
SMALL BUSINESSES TO CAPITAL. IT
ALSO IS DOUBLE BECAUSE CRIME
CAL REVOLVED LOAN. THERE'S NO
APPROPRIATION FOR THIS BILL
ALLOWS THE ADMINISTRATION THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE FUNDS INTO
THIS FUN. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY US FOREVER. THANK
YOU MISTER STRUGGLE TO YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVENTY EIGHT THIS BILL
CREATES THE CLIMATE CATALYST
REVOLVING LOAN FUND. AN
AUTHORIZES THE ISSUANCE OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. OF BOND
DEBT. TO FUND THIS PROGRAM WHEN
I ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THIS MORNING WHAT THEIR
PLANS WERE FOR REPAYING THESE
REVENUE BONDS. THEY DIDN'T HAVE
AN ANSWER IN FACT THEY SAID
THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY
INTENTION. OF USING BONDS TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM SO I THEN
ASKED WHY THE AUTHORIZATION
LANGUAGE. WAS IN THIS BILL AND
THEY REPLIED WELL WE MIGHT WANT
TO IN THE FUTURE COLLEGE I
SUBMIT TO YOU. THAT IF THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO USE
BOND AT AND DRIVE THE STATE
FURTHER INTO DEBT ESPECIALLY IN
A YEAR WHEN WE HAVE A FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
DEFICIT. THAT HE COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE FOR APPROVAL
WHEN HE INTENDS TO DO THAT I
ORIGINAL VOTE. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. QUIRK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. IS THERE A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT. AS FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
TWELVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARKAN KURT IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB SEVENTY NINE.
OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
HUMAN SERVICES IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER TECH.
THEY WERE. AB SEVEN ODDS ARE
SHE SERVICE TRAIL BILL. CHRIS
IS MORE. SIX MONTH WELL FOR TO
WORK FOR. STREAMLINED OUR CAL.
FACILITIES SO IF YOU TO RETAIN
AND ROLL LEASE. FOR THE PROCESS
TOWARDS CAL FRESH AND MEDI CAL
COLIN WOMAN. SO THAT PRE
POPULATE OF SEMI AND THE P.
POLLUTION SEMI IN. REPORTING
FORMS MAKING IT EASY. TO ROLL
AND BY OF THIS. TIME IT ALSO
PROVIDES FLEX FOR RE. FOR PROOF
BY ANY. UPDATES AS A HEALTH
SUPPLE FOR NON MY DEPEND IN
TERMS HOUSING. THE CONTINUED IN.
ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS FOR CARE
GIVERS AND TWENTY. SURE
OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB SO NINE.
THIS TRAILER BILL. CHANGES THE
HUMANS PROGRAMS IN THE STATE TO
MAKE THEM MORE EFFICIENT AND
EASIER TO ADMINISTER THESE
CHANGES ARE VERY SUPPORT OF A
LARGE AND I VOTE. DOCTOR
ARAMBULA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY NINE OR
HUMAN SERVICES ON THE BUS THIS
BILL HELPS TO SUPPORT AND
PROTECT MANY OF THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAM SUCH- WORKS CAL FRESH I
HSS FOSTER CARE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND MORE THESE ARE THE
PROGRAMS THAT HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. I'M
GLAD I DID I OUR KIDS AND OUR
LEAD IN BOTH HOUSES AND ARE
GOING OUR RECORD AND WRIST THE
IMP OF THESE PER. I ALL ALL THE
WORK ON THIS BILL. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU FOR ALL YOUR
WORK I'M ALSO GRATEFUL THAT NOT
ONLY HAS THERE BEEN SUCH STRONG
ADVOCACY FOR THESE PROGRAMS BUT
THAT THERE ALSO HAS BEEN A
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED TO
EXPAND THEM AND TO CREATE
FLEXIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE AB
SEVENTY NINE WILL HELP CORRECT
A POLICY THAT HAS BEEN A IN
FACT BEFORE TOO LONG OKAY WORKS
TIME FOR. AB SEVENTY NINE WILL
EXTEND THIS TIME CLOCK TO SIXTY
MONTHS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THIS PROGRAM CAL WORKS IS
A PROGRAM THAT PREDOMINANTLY
SERVES WOMEN. WOMEN OF COLOR
WHO ARE SEEKING TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND AT A TIME LIKE NOW WE
SHOULD FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
GOVERNMENT WORK FOR. AND THIS
SIXTY MONTH TIME CLOCK THAT WE
RECTIFYING WILL ALLOW US TO PUT
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. SO WHAT
I'VE SEEN IN MY COMMUNITY
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN OUT AND
ABOUT. AT FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS
RECENTLY. IS THE NEED. THAT WE
HAVE IN SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND HONORED THAT
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THIS NEED
IS BEING COLLECTED AND
RESPONDED TO WITHIN THIS
BUDGET. BY ALLOWING OUR
COUNTIES TO EXPAND REACH
ACTIVITIES THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE AND WHINING ELIGIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE WITHIN CAL FRESH.
AB SEVENTY NINE CREATE SOME
VACATION BETWEEN THESE PROGRAM.
SO THAT PART. ABLE TO OUR THE
SIR. AT POSSIBLE. IT WILL ALSO
HELP TO HIDE FROM THE SIX
NECESSITY OF WATER BY EXTEND
THE SAFETY WATER SUPPLE BY PIE
PRO. SO THAT FAMILY CAN PER
SAFE DRINKING FROM THEIR CAL
FRESHMAN. OTHER LANGUAGE IN AB
SEVENTY NINE ON AYE HSS AND
AGING AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES HELP STRENGTHEN THESE
PROGRAMS TO HELP FAMILIES STAY
HOME AND ME MAINTAIN BOTH THEIR
DIGNITY AND THEIR INDEPENDENCE.
AND FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH AND
ARE CARE GIVERS AND ARE NON
MINOR DEPENDENCE OF BILLS THIS
BILL WILL HELP TO PROVIDE THE
STABILITY THAT THEY NEED. AB
SEVENTY NINE ALSO INCLUDES SO
MANY OTHER FLEXIBILITY IS THAT
WE NEED AT THIS TIME THAT OUR
ADMINISTRATION HAS HELPED PAVE
THE WAY FOR BY ALLOWING FOR
TELLY AND VIDEO CONFERENCING
APPOINTMENTS INTERVIEWS AND
CERTIFICATIONS SO THEIR
FAMILIES CAN ACCESS THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY NEED.
WITHOUT PUTTING THEIR HEALTH
AND SAFETY AT RISK. I AM PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I ASK
FOR ANOTHER VOTE HERE TODAY.
THANK DOCTOR REGULAR. IN
ADDITION DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE ITEM. CLARK WILL THE ROLE.
RESERVE AT ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. OUR. WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIX A. B. EIGHTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. MISTER TECH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB AT ONE REAL
PRIZES THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES QUALITY ASSURANCE
FEET. THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
ESTABLISHES A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO DEVELOP A NEW
QUALITY PAYMENT SYSTEM TO
BEGIN. A JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. IT ALSO PROVIDES
TEMPORARY FLEXIBILITY IS FOR
COUNTIES THE OPERATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT. THE
RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY RIVAL.
MR OF AN AWFULLY MISTER SPEAKER
RISE IT OFF. DAY BE A ONE. THIS
BILL X. A STATEWIDE TAX ON
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
WHICH IS PROBLEMATIC IN A YEAR
WHEN WE HAVE A FIFTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT I
REGION OVER. SEEING NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
BUDGET ITEM. CORPORAL. IT IS
OUT OF OUR MEMBERS ARE DESERVE
A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. THIS TAKES THIRTY FOR
ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY SIX NO NOT
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVEN A. B. EIGHTY.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
ACCOLADE TO HAVE HEALTH AND
MAKING A PROVISION OF FOURTH
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
PRIVILEGE TO THE BUDGET THAT
YOU'RE TECH. THANK YOU AB AT IS
ALL HEALTHCARE TRAILER BILL.
ESTABLISHES THE HEALTH CARE
PAYMENTS DATA SYSTEM OF THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. ALSO
QUALIFIES VARIOUS MEDI CAL
PROGRAM FLEXIBILITY IS ADOPTED
IN RESPONSE TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN. IMPORTANTLY REQUIRES
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET THAT THE
FULL SCOPE OF MEDI CAL COVERAGE
FOR SENIORS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS BE
PRIORITIZED. FOR INCLUSION. IF
THE FISCAL CONDITIONS ARE
ALLOWED TO DO SO WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ICE RIVAL FOR AB
AT. THE TROUBLE THANK YOU
RICHEST HELLO MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS TRAILER BILL
ARE SUPPORTABLE UNFORTUNATELY.
THE PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT
EXPANDS FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL TO
UNDOCUMENTED CEDARS IN A
PRIORITIZE FACTION IS VERY
TROUBLING AND HERE'S THE
REASON. WE'RE HAVING TO MAKE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF CUTS
THIS YEAR TO MANY PROGRAMS THAT
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS DEPEND
ON. FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S A
TRIGGER CUT OF ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY AND- THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. IF WE VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL TODAY WERE SAYING.
THAT WE'D RATHER PRIORITIZE
EXPANSION OF AN ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM. THEY PUT THAT MONEY
BACK INTO EDUCATION. I THINK
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE TO TAKE THAT
ACTION TODAY WE SHOULD WAIT FOR
FUTURE BUDGET YEAR TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS I ORIGINAL VOTE.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. THANK YOU
MA'AM MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB AT I AM
HUMBLED BY THE WORK THAT HAS
GONE INTO SECURING THE BUDGET
DEAL THAT KEEPS COVERAGE AND
CARE INTACT AS OUR STATE
CONTINUES TO AGGRESSIVELY
COMBAT THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AB AT WILL HELP TO
PROVIDE ACCESS AND QUALITY
HEALTHCARE TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THIS
BILL WILL SUPPORTER STATES
MEDICAL RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN BY CODIFYING ANY
RELATED FEDERALLY APPROVED
WAIVERS AND FLEXIBILITY EASE
INTO STATE LAW. THIS MEANS THAT
OUR STATE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR THE TREATMENT OF
UNINSURED INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS BECAUSE AS WE KNOW ALL
TOO WELL THE HELP OF ALL OF US
DEPENDS ON THE HEALTH OF EACH
OF US AND THAT IS WHY I AM
HEARTENED TO SEE INTENT
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN AB AT THE
RINGS ONE STEP CLOSER TO
ACHIEVING FOR ALL SENIOR.
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. I BELIEVE THAT IS A FEW
RIGHT AND IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS OUR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND OUR
SENIORS. EXPANDING HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SHOULD BE OUR TOP
PRIORITY. I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS IS
ACTUALIZED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND AS WE EXPAND
HEALTHCARE SO MUST WE ALSO
SUPPORT OUR PROVIDERS THAT IS
WHY I AM GLAD THAT. BUDGET ALSO
FOR. OUR FIFTY SIX DOLLARS ARE
TO. AND THAT AND COMMUNITY.
MEDICAL PROVIDERS PREVENTATIVE
HEALTH SERVICES FOR WOMEN AS
WELL AS THE TRAINING OF OUR
PHYSICIANS AND MEDICAL WORK
FORCE OF THE FUTURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE HERE TODAY. SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADULT QUIRK LOCAL ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A AS FIFTY SIX KNOWS
NINE SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT A. B. EIGHTY TWO.
OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NATURALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MR TANK.
THANK YOU THIS IS OUR GENERAL
GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
ESTABLISHES A SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURS FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVE. WHICH
IS A SMALL TEND NOT TO MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT FOR LIMITED
ENGLISH SPEAKING IMMIGRANTS WHO
HAVE A HARD TIME BEING PART OF
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. ALLOW THE DMV THIS
CLOSE TO EDT EASTERN
INFORMATION FOR PURPOSES
RELATED TAX ADMINISTRATION. IT
ALSO SHIFT SWORN OFFICERS FROM
THE DIVISION OF INVESTIGATIONS
TO THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOREVER. MR OF AN OF THE-
JUST BAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION
DAVEY EIGHTY TWO. THIS PROGRAM
ESTABLISHES THE SEED INITIATIVE
THAT WILL PROVIDE MICROLOANS
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS SEEKING
TO START BUSINESSES. NOW ALL OF
YOU KNOW THAT I AM A STRONG
PROPONENT OF ENTREPRENEURSHIP
IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD SUPPORT
OF PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
MICROLOANS TO ALL CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA BUT TO SINGLE OUT
ONLY THE UNDOCUMENTED WITH
TAXPAYER MONEY. IS AN
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS I ORIGINAL VOTE. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
FOR CLUB WHERE ALL. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS EIGHT. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM TEN. FILE
ITEM TEN AB NINETY. COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET MAC
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION A
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
RELATED TO THE BUDGET MISTER
TECH. THANK YOU MISTRESS MISTER
SPEAKER EIGHTY NINETY IS OUR
TRANSPORTATION FOR THE BILL. IT
HOLDS TRANSIT OPERATORS
HARMLESS TO REDUCE THE IMPACT
OF LOW RIDERSHIP FROM KOBE
NINETEEN. REQUIRES AN AVIATION
FUEL RETAILER TO PROVIDE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION WITH
QUARTERLY INFORMATION. AND
LASTLY DELAYS THE DUE DATE OF
THIS YEAR OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
BUSINESS PLAN. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. MR
OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN OPPOSITION AB NINETY. THIS
TRAILER BILL DELAY IS THE
DELIVERY OF A CONSTRUCTION
UPDATE FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY THUS DECREASING BALL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AT THAT AGENCY. THE REASON WHY
THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT THIS CONSTRUCTION UPDATE
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN DUE
JUST BEFORE THIS LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO BE ASKED TO MAKE A
DECISION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
TO APPROPRIATE OVER FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS OF FUNDING. TO
COMPLETE THAT PROJECT
COLLEAGUES THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY AND THE HIGH SPEED
TRANSIT- PROJECT IS OVER ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. OVER BUDGET
RIGHT NOW. IT'S OVER A DECADE
BEHIND SCHEDULE IT NEEDS MORE
OVERSIGHT FROM THIS BODY NOT
LESS. MY ORIGINAL VOTE. MR FALL
YOUR RECORD AS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETY THE
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET TRAILER
BILL THIS BILL INEXPLICABLY
WAVES THE REQUIREMENTFOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY TO
SUBMIT A CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
UPDATE TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WITH EVERY PROGRESS
REPORT THERE ARE MORE DELAYS
AND COST ESTIMATES CONTINUE TO
CLIMB. DESPITE ALL THE PROBLEMS
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED WITH THE
HIGHLY MISMANAGED IN COSTLY
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. THIS
BILL GOES COMPLETELY IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION. WE NEED MORE
OVERSIGHT. MORE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND MORE SCRUTINY. FOR THIS IS
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
THAT WAS SLATED TO COST. THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS ORIGINALLY NOW
IT'S BEING PROJECTED TO COST
CLOSE TO NINETY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. THIS IS THREE TIMES OF
OVER BUDGET IN OVER TEN YEARS
BEHIND SCHEDULE. MILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING
POURED INTO THIS PROJECT EVERY
DAY DURING THAT TIME TODAY WHEN
WE HAVE A MASSIVE BUDGET
DEFICIT AND THERE IS
THREATENING CUTS EDUCATION.
TEACHERS FIRST RESPONDERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS THIS
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES TO THE
PUBLIC AT THE MISALIGNMENT OF
PRIORITIES IN THIS BUDGET. THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PUBLIC DESERVE A REGULAR
PROGRESS REPORT IT IS
IRRESPONSIBLE NOT TO DEMAND A
REPORT WE ALL KNOW THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTALLY FLAWED PROJECT.
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
MISMANAGEMENT AND COST OVERRUNS
THIS BILL AND THESE PROVISIONS
DEFY ALL COMMON SENSE. LESS
ACCOUNTABILITY DOES NOT TO FIX
THE PROBLEM I URGING OF A-
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF A RISE FOR THE
EIGHT Nó SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB NINETY
TWO. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETY TWO BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET NATURALLY OF RESOURCE
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
RELAY TO THE- YESTERDAY. THANK
YOU FOR JUST THIS IS OUR
RESOURCES BILL PERMISSIBLE OF
LAND ACID BUT CLEAN UP FUND FOR
SPECIFIED ACTIVITIES THAT
AUTHORIZES THE WATER TO A
SEARCH FOR ONE FOR A ONE WATER
QUALITY SEARCH PART OF THE
COMPLETION OF SEEK WHAT THE
SALVAGE THE NEW FIA FOR THE OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO
SUPPORT. THE SOCIAL PROGRAM
COSTS FOR TWELVE THE LAW
PROHIBITS CONFINED AVAILABLE
THE LAST WE STOP WHICH IS THE
GOOD NAY AUTHORITY FUND THE
FIFTY FIFTY OF MANAGEMENT PART
ON FEDERAL. VETERANS ASK
PRIVATE. MR OVER NINETY. THANK
YOU MISTER COLLEGE MY PROM WITH
THIS BILL IS ONE OF. THIS BILL
IMPLY DOES AND DOZENS OF POLICY
CHANGES TO AREAS IN CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW MY QUESTION IS WHY
ARE THESE IN A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL AND IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THEM IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
IS RELATED TO THE BUDGET. THEN
WHY DO IT IN A YEAR WHEN THE
BUDGET PROCESS WAS SO
CONSTRAINED. THIS BILL ALSO
RAISES FEES ON THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IN A
YEAR WHEN THAT INDUSTRY IS JUST
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE. I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK MEASURE OF
AN ALL THESE SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. QUIRK LIBERAL. IT
IS AT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
TO DECIDE ABOUT. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I FIFTY FIVE NO
SEVENTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWELVE. AB NINETY THREE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY THREE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET THE
TAXATION OF MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER TECH THANK
MISTER SPEAKER AB NINETY THREE
EXPANDS OR EARN INCOME TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM TO FILERS I TENS
WITH ONE OR MORE CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF SIX. THIS WAS A
MAJOR PRIORITY IN OUR BUDGET OF
LAST YEAR WE WEREN'T A TO GET
IT DONE FOR ALL THE AYE TERROR
FILERS WE OPEN THIS YEAR WITH
THE HOPES OF AN EXPANDED TO ALL
THE I TEN FATHER'S THE GIVEN
THE BUDGET CONSTRAINTS WE WERE
ABLE TO DO A PIECE OF IT. BUT
IT'S A HUGE A FIRST UP
ESPECIALLY FOR SO MANY FAMILIES
WHO ARE IN CRITICAL NEED THE
REASON THIS IS SO IMPORTANT AS
THESE ARE HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES WHO CAN'T
GET UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
OVERSTATING AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
OUT OF WORK FOR OVER OUT FOR.
FAMILIES CHECK IT OUT. TO THE
FUNDS. SO THIS IS THE- PROGRAM.
TO HELP THOSE FAMILIES IN NEED
WHO ARE WHO HAVE BEEN. AND HAVE
WORKED IN I HAD THE PAYING TALK.
TO GET CRITICAL AT THIS VERY
IMPORTANT WITH THE A
RESPECTFULLY ASK A VOTE ON A.
B. NINE THREE. THIS TO MISS
SPEAKER RISE IN OUR- AB NINETY
THREE I WISH MORE US WERE
TALKING THE CALL. INVOLVED IN
THIS PROGRAM. THE I. THE YEAR'S
GOING TO CALL A HUNDRED
SEVENTY. MILLION DOLLARS LET'S
TALK ABOUT THE- OF THE EIGHTIES.
WHICH IS TO IN. PEOPLE GO TO
WORK OUR PROBLEM. IN THE STATE.
RIGHT NOW WITHOUT AND THE WAY
IS NOT THE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
WORK WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH JOBS
TO GO AROUND FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO WORK. SO I WOULD-
SUGGESTED THAT THIS WOULD BE
BETTER DONE IN A FUTURE YEAR.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT WERE FACING
A FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SHORTFALL THIS YEAR. I
ORIGINAL VOTE. MS RIVAS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSED
EXTENSION OF CALLIE ITC-
STIPULATED IN AB NINETY THREE-
UNDER THIS PROPOSED EXTENSION
TAXPAYERS HUGHES AND I TEND TO
FILE. THEIR TAXES WITH CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF SIX WILL NOT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR CALLIE ITC. I'M
KELLY ITC HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
EFFECTIVELY HELP THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN POVERTY. AND
NOW AN ADDITIONAL FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE CAN RECEIVE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. MEMBERS THIS
EXTENSION IS UNDOUBTEDLY A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION HOWEVER
WE HAVE A MORAL RESPONSIBILITY
TO DO MUCH MORE OF TO
AMELIORATE THE FINANCIAL
SITUATION OF UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES AND THEIR CHILDREN
THESE FAMILIES KEEP OUR ECONOMY
GOING AND PAY TAXES EXPANDING
ACCESS TO KELLY ITC. TO ALL I
TEN FILERS IS JUST THE RIGHT
THING TO DO I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON ENSURING.
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
TAKING CARE OF THANK YOU.
THANKS RIVAS MISS RAY YES IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LIKE TO RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY THREE.
AT MEMBERS JUST RECENTLY WE
VOTED ON A BILL SENT IT OVER TO
THE SENATE THAT WOULD EXTEND
KELLY I TO SEE TO ALL I TEN
FILERS BECAUSE OF THE. BUDGET
SITUATION THE LAW IN THIS PART
BILL EXTENDS THE KELLY I TO SEE
CREDIT ONLY TO THOSE I TEN
FILERS WITH CHILDREN UNDER SIX
THE COST IS UNDER FIFTY MILLION
IT IS NOT OVER ONE HUNDRED AS
WAS NOTED BY MY COLLEAGUE I
URGE AN AYE VOTE ON. AB NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
DIVISIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM CORP LOCAL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WERE. IT IS OUT OF
OUT CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS OUR CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
FIVE THIRTEEN AB ONE HUNDRED
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
HUNDRED BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND ACRYLATE A STATE
GOVERNMENT MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OR FOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER TECH.
THINK ABOUT SPEAKER AB ONE
HUNDRED IS OUR GENERAL COVERS
OUR SECOND GOVERNMENT TRAILER
BILL ALLOWS LOCAL REASONABLY
RELATED TO ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATION DURING THE CALL
THAT NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO BE A
REIMBURSABLE EXPENDITURE IT
ALSO ESTABLISHES THE ALFORD HE
OFFERS SEISMIC SAFETY
COMMISSION AS A SEPARATE UNIT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
OPERATIONS OFFICE OF THE
MINISTRIES OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. MR OF ADOPTING MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE HUNDRED THIS TRAILER BILL
PROVIDES REIMBURSEMENT TO
COUNTIES FOR INCREASED.
ELECTION COSTS RELATED TO THE
CORONA VIRUS EPIDEMIC THESE
REIMBURSEMENTS ARE BOTH
NECESSARY I AM SUPPORTABLE
ARJUN I'VE A- SEEING THEIR
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE AT. CLARK WELL OVER THERE
ALL MEMBERS. USER TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY KNOWS
SO AMEND ARE CAN IN THIS IS
FILE I FOR. AB ONE OR TWO. OR
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH TWO
BY THE CAN ON BUDGET AND AKRON
OVER TIME SAVE IN MAKING
APPROACH ARE FOR TO TAKE A
IMMEDIATELY BEVERLY TO THE
BUDGET. MR CHECK. THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKER AB ONE OF TRANCE RESP.
FOR THE- IN FORCE THE
COUNSELORS. PROGRAMMER FORSMAN
FROM EDT TO FTP MAKES OTHERS
CHANGE TO THE CAL FOR PROGRAM.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
ABOUT. MR OBERNOLTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION AB ONE OR TWO THIS
BILL IS SHIFTING ENFORCEMENT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CAL SAVERS
FROM THE EDT TO THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AND ALTHOUGH THERE
MIGHT BE EXPEDIENT THIS YEAR
WHEN THE L. ET IS FACING AN
UNPRECEDENTED- WORKLOAD- THIS
IS A DECISION THAT WE'RE MAKING
FOR ALL FUTURE YEARS AS WELL
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT THIS
CHANGE. WILL RESULT IN THE LOSS
OF DUE PROCESS PROTECTION FOR
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA I
ORIGINAL VOTE. SEEING NOTICED
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. OR CALL
THE ROLL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. IT
WOULD. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL
TIME BUT I AS FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN. AB SEVENTY FIVE
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
MACLAINE TO THE STATE BUDGET
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUT THE
BILL MISTER TECH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB SEVENTY. IS
ARE SUPPLEMENTAL. BILL THE
MEN'S THE TWENTY NINETEEN THE
BUDGET TO ADDRESS FOR HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILLION IN AND
ANTICIPATED EXPENDITURES. THIS
IS A VERY TYPICAL BUDGET BILL
THAT WE DO EVERY YEAR TO DEAL
WITH ANY OF THE PREVIOUS YEARS
ON ANTICIPATED CREDITORS. LAST
YEAR WE HAD LARGE COSTS RELATED
POWER SHUT OFF AND FIRE CROSSES
WITH THE CAMPFIRE. FUNDING ALSO
TO BEGIN LAYOFFS STATE
AFFILIATED FAIRGROUNDS. THESE
COSTS OR SOON TO TWENTY BUDGET
PACKAGE WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. MR OF AN OPENING.
LET'S JUST I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY FIVE THIS TRAILER
BILL APPROPRIATES HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP COUNTIES WITH THE COSTS OF
DISASTER RECOVERY IN THE
CURRENT 200-019-2000 TWENTY
FISCAL YEAR IN ADDITION THIS-
MONEY- IT WILL GO TO THE COUNTY
OF BUTTE FOR RECOVERY OF THE
CAMPFIRE THESE ARE VERY
NECESSARY IN SUPPORT OF A LARGE
AND I VOTE. SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COUPLE OF. RESERVE OUT ALL
MEMBERS THAT IT IS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT. THIS
IS FILE ITEM. SEVENTEEN AB. ONE
OF THREE. CORPORATE SOME REAL
ONE OH THREE BY THE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET ACCOLADES
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SO MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TO
RELATE TO THE BUDGET MISTER
TECH THEY OF A SPEAKER AB ONE
OH THREE PROVIDES RELIEF TO
EMPLOYERS WHOSE EMPLOYEES ARE
EMPLOYED AS A DIRECT OR
INDIRECT REASON RELATED TO
COVERT NINETEEN IT ALSO MEANT
THE CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CODE SO PAYMENT FOR
TWENTY SIX WEEKS WILL BE
REIMBURSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH ADOPTION OF
THIS PROVISION WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY RESTAURANT. MR OF
AN OPENING MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OF
THREE. I AM VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THE LEGISLATURE TAKING ACTION
ON THIS ISSUE THIS WILL- KEEP
HOLD EMPLOYERS ACROSS THE STATE
OF FLORIDA CALIFORNIA HARMLESS
FOR SOMETHING THAT WAS
ABSOLUTELY NOT THEIR FAULT. IT
WILL PREVENT. THE FURLOUGH FOR
EMPLOYEES RELATED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS PRICES FOR BEING-
EXPRESSED AGAINST THEIR
EXPERIENCE RATIO ONE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE RATES
ARE CALCULATED NEXT YEAR.
HOWEVER I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS WE
HAVE A LARGER ISSUE HERE AND A
LARGER PROBLEM TO SOLVE. IN THE
COMING YEAR AND THAT IS HOW WE
ARE GOING TO PAY. THE MONEY
THAT WE'RE BORROWING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BACK. WHILE
WE BORROWED OVER SIX BILLION
DOLLARS SO FAR THIS YEAR
ENTITLED TWELVE LOANS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY. TO REPAIR THOSE AND WE
NEED TO DO IT IN SUCH A WAY
THAT DOES NOT FALL ON THE BACKS
OF EMPLOYERS IN CARE BORN IN.
THE LAST TIME WE TOOK THESE
TWELVE ALL THESE TIME TWELVE
LOANS OUT. IN THE GREAT
RECESSION WITH. ENDED UP PAYING
BACK THE STATE FAILED TO SO AND
IT RESULTED IN BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF DESIGN
FOR. OVER INTO. CAN I WHILE
THAT. AND AGAIN BUT I'M
DELIGHTED WERE THIS FOR A BI AN
AYE VOTE. THIS NOTE. DISCUSSION
CORP WILL OPEN. WHO IS OUT OF A
ALL MEMBERS OF ARE OF A. ALL
MEMBER VOTE. THERE VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSER ALL ABOUT ICE THREE
NO ZERO SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONCUR IN. MEMBERS PURSUANT TO
S. RULE SEVENTY POINT TWO I
AMBER. AB ONE OH FIVE. TO
REVENUEAND TAXATION COMMITTEE.
THE REST BACK. IN FILE ORDER
THIS IS FOR FY EIGHTEEN. AB ONE
NINETEEN. CORPORATE SOME BILL
ONE NINETEEN BY SOME MEMBER
TING ACRYLATE STATE EMPLOYMENT
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET MISTER
TECH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB ONE NINETEEN CONTAINED THE
MO YOU. FOR BAR UNITS EIGHTEEN
THE PSYCHED. KNOWLEDGE PAY AND
SIX WHICH IS C. P. O. N. IT
ALSO REFLECTS REASON.
BARGAINING RE WITH ARE YOU
LOCAL ONE FOR. THESE OF BARK
UNIT OF GREEN. RESULTED IN
ALMOST THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS FOR THIS YEAR'S FISCAL
YEAR BUDGET WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB ONE NINETEEN. THE SHERMAN
OFFICE MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE NINETEEN.
BUT THIS TRAILER BILL RATIFIES
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ABLE USE
WITH DIFFERENT STATE BARGAINING
UNITS AND MOST OF THOSE
AGREEMENTS ARE VERY
SUPPORTABLE. HOWEVER I HAVE A
BIG PROBLEM WITH SECTION THREE
OF THIS TRAILER BILL. WHICH
GIVES THE ADMINISTRATION THE
AUTHORITY TO RATIFY ANY MMO
YOU THAT'S ENTERED INTO BETWEEN
NOW AND THE END OF THE MONTH
WITH ZERO AUTHORITY OR APPROVAL
FROM THIS LEGISLATURE.
COLLEAGUES THAT IS ABDICATING
OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT. OVER THOSE
AGREEMENTS AND ALLOWING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO SIGN THEM
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IS IN THEM
THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE AND I
ORIGINAL VOTE. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF A I SIXTY FOUR NO
SEVEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY. AB AT THREE CORPORATE.
SOME OF- EIGHTY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACCOLADE A
HOUSING IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET YESTERDAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AB EIGHTY THREE
IS OUR HOUSING TRAILER BILL.
BUT THIS ALLOCATE THREE UNDER
THIRTY MILLION TO THE NATIONAL
MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT FUN FOR
HOMEOWNERS. YOU'LL RECALL THAT
THIS WAS PART OF A LAWSUIT THE-
MONEY NEEDED TO GO TO
HOMEOWNERS AS WELL SO TENANTS
AND- HAVE A VERY. SPECIFIC
AMOUNT OF SPENDING AROUND
HOUSING ISSUES IT ALSO PROVIDES
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ROUND TWO OF THE PHARMACIST
HOUSING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH IS MONEY THAT'S GOING TO
GO TO CITIES COUNTIES CONTINUES
OF CARE TO AGAIN- DO A HOME IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE PROJECT ROOM
KEY. IT ALSO ALLIANCE. AND
GUIDELINES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TAX CREDIT- COMMITTEE. THE
CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE TO
ADMINISTER THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CUTS. WITHOUT A
RESPECT FOR US FOR A VOTE FOR A
BI EIGHTY THREE. MISTER THE- MR
I RISE IN. OF A AT. THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SPECIAL
DEPOSIT FUND. MONEY WILL HELP
HOMEOWNERS AND STRUGGLING
RENTERS ROCK CALIFORNIA- TO PAY
THEIR BILLS AND TO KEEP THEIR
HOUSING THIS IS LONG OVERDUE
AND IRISH. I VOTE. THE MEASURE
OF THE MISS CORPS SILVA YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND- TODAY I AND OF A
AT. WE ALL AGREE THAT THE
ECONOMIC OUTLOOK OF OUR STATE
LOOKS MUCH DIFFERENT NOW WITH
THE EFFECTS OF COVERT NINETEEN
BEFORE KOBE NINETEEN WE HAD A
HOUSING CALL CRISIS AND NOW
WITH KOBE NINETEEN WE CAN
EXPECTED EVEN WORSE CRISIS AS
WE KNOW MANY OF THE
MORATORIUM'S FOR MORTGAGES AND
FOR EVICTIONS ARE WILL BE
RUNNING OUT TO WE ARE GOING TO
SEE. FAMILIES FACED WITH MAJOR
ISSUES AS WHERE ARE THEY GOING
TO LIVE HOUSING IS ALREADY ON
AFFORDABLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THIS BILL WILL MAKE A STEP
TOWARDS HELPING THOSE WHO ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE RELATED TO
HOUSING. WE MAY NOT LIKE
EVERYTHING IN THIS BUDGET OR
AGREE ON ALL THINGS BUT I HOPE
WE CAN AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE HOUSING
FAMILIES WOMEN. OUR MILITARY OF
SPUR SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN AND
THAT WE ARE WORKING TO GET
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET. WHAT IS
IN THIS BY. FOR US TODAY IS
THAT WE ARE LOOKING TO HOUSE
PEOPLE BY ADDING THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. TO OUR HOUSING
ASSISTANT PREVENTION PROGRAM
THE H. OUT PROGRAM AND ALSO
WORKING TOWARDS CONTINUING TO
FUND OUR PROJECT REACH ROOM KEY
PROGRAM. I WOULD ASK THAT AS WE
COME BACK TO SESSION THAT WE
LOOK TO MAKE THE HAVE THE
PROJECT ROOM KEY PROGRAM MORE
PERMANENT BY OUR STATE BUYING
THOSE HOTELS AND MOTELS TO
KEEP. SOME OF THE HAVE A
HOUSING PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THOSE- HOTELS HOUSE WE WILL
CERTAINLY NEED MORE FUNDING IN
THE FUTURE BUT THIS IS A STEP
TOWARDS KEEPING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
VOTE ON A BRICK. A. B. EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU MISS QUIRK
SILVA MISTER CHAIR DAVID CHIU
IN THE REAR OF THE YOU
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO JOIN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
THANKING THE GOVERNOR AND OR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP. WITH
DOING WHAT THEY CAN AND WHAT WE
CAN TO ADDRESS ARE VERY INTENSE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC RECESSION
AND BUDGET DEFICIT. AS IS
ALREADY BEEN LAID OUT THIS
BUDGET WILL INCLUDE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
HOMEOWNERS FOR MORTGAGE RELIEF.
THREE MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS FOR HOMELESSNESS TO THE
HIGH PROGRAM- TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS PROJECTION DEFENSE.
MOVING FOR PROJECT ROOM KEY
PROGRAM THAT WILL ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO HOPEFULLY
PURCHASE HOTELS AND MOTELS TO
KEEP ALMOST INDIVIDUALS HOUSE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATIONS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TAX RATE PROGRAM AND A
CERTAIN THE PRIORITY FOR
HOUSING FIRST INDIVIDUALS
LEAVING OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM WE ALL KNOW THERE'S SO
MUCH MORE WE NEED TO DO DURING
THIS HOUSING CRISIS. BUT AT
LEAST WITH THIS BUDGET WE ARE
CONTINUING TO FOCUS AND WE WILL
KEEP DOING MORE WORK ON IT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER. AND WITHOUT. CORD BLOOD.
IT IS OUT OF OUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A HI
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS TOO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
EIGHTY FOUR SEPARATE. SOME AGO
EIGHTY FOUR BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET ACCOLADE IN THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
TECH THANK YOU AB AT FOR RE
DIRECT THE SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION CALPERS SCHOOL POOL OF
MIDDLE PENSION PAYMENT TO MIX
OF PLANTING PAYMENTS TO SCHOOL
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION RATES
REDIRECT THE ONE POINT SIX FOUR
BILLION GENERAL FUND CAL STAR
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
PROVIDE IN NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET ACT TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
SUPPLANTING PAYMENT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ARE THE BUDGET PACKAGE ALSO
REFER YOU OF. PROP TWO DEBT
FUND TO MAKE A POOR OF STATE
PAYMENTS ON CAL STARS ON THE
LIVE IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR THE- THIS ROAD NOTHING.
THIS SPEAKER I RISE IN ALL. TO
AB EIGHTY FOUR THIS BILL
DIVERTS TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS INTENDED TO
REDUCE. LONG TERM. IMPLY
ABILITIES FOR A CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS AND INSTEAD USES THAT
MONEY TO PAY CURRENT YEAR
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS.
COLLEAGUES CAL STIRS HAS
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES OVER
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT
NOW CALPERS HAS UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES OF OVER SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS THIS MONEY WAS
SUPPOSED TO START ADDRESSING
THAT PROBLEM. AND EVERY YEAR WE
WAIT TO ADDRESS IT THE PROBLEM
IS JUST GOING TO GET WORSE AND
IT'S GOING TO GET MORE
DIFFICULT TO SOLVE IN THE
FUTURE I ORIGINAL VOTE. I SEE
NO OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLICK WELL THEY'RE
ALL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FOR THE A NOSE
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK UP AND FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM Q. ACA FOR
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSUMING
CONSTITUTION WOMEN FOR BY SOME
WE WERE MULLIN ANOTHER AN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS. MISTER
MELLING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO PRESENT A CA
FOR WHICH I AM JOINT AUTHORING
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM CAMPBELL
AND WOULD ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO VOTE IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS PROVIDED THAT THEY
ARE EIGHTEEN BY THE TIME OF THE
GENERAL ELECTION. ACA FOR WOULD
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGEST VOTER
DEMOGRAPHIC AND BOOST YOUTH
PARTICIPATION IN OUR ELECTIONS
THIS IDEA IS NOT A NEW ONE.
NEARLY HALF OF STATES IN THE U.
S. ALREADY ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PRIMARIES AND CAUCUSES. FIRST
TIME VOTER SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN A
FULL ELECTION CYCLE PRIMARY AND
GENERAL. IN OTHER WORDS IF
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO VOTE IN THE
GENERAL YOU SHOULD BE ALLOWED
TO HELP SHAPE THE CHOICES IN
THE PRIMARY ELECTION. NOT ONLY
DOES RESEARCH INDICATE THAT THE
YOUTH POPULATION AS A LOS
TURNOUT LEVELS OF ANY AGE
DEMOGRAPHIC. BUT STUDIES ALSO
SHOW. THAT VOTING IS HABIT
FORMING ONCE A PERSON THOSE
HERE SHE IS MORE LIKELY TO DO
SO AGAIN. EARLY INVOLVEMENT IN
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS FOR FIRST
TIME VOTERS SHOULD BE A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR THIS REASON. FOR
ME THIS EFFORT IS PERSONAL. MY
FATHER A FORMER HIGH SCHOOL
CIVICS TEACHER AUTHORED THIS
MEASURE. ON THIS FLOOR A COUPLE
OF DIFFERENT TIMES AND I'VE
CONTINUE THIS EFFORT MYSELF
THREE TIMES. THE TIME HAS
FINALLY ARRIVED. FOR A CA FOR.
CALIFORNIA WHICH LEADS ON SO
MANY BALLOT ACCESS ISSUES IS
BEHIND THE CURVE WHEN IT COMES
TO PRIORITIZING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. AMONG OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE. AS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT THIS MEASURE WOULD GO
BEFORE THE VOTERS TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION EASIER FOR ALSO
ENJOYS STRONG SUPPORT FROM OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE. ALEX
PADILLA TODAY IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE OF US ON THIS FLOOR
ENSURE THE VOTERS BE WILLING TO
A POWER CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGEST
VOTERS ENCOURAGING THEM TO
BECOME LIFELONG PARTICIPANTS.
IN THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL ACT
DEMOCRACY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN MISTER LOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I OF
ALSO RISE AND SUPPORT AND THINK
THAT ARE JOIN AUTHOR FOR HIS A
CONTINUED EFFORTS AND
PERSEVERANCE ON THIS ISSUE AS
THIS IS NOT ONLY VERY PERSONAL
THIS FAMILY- BUT VERY MUCH
DEDICATED TO INCREASING CIVIC
PARTICIPATION OF THIS IS ON
CONCURRENCE AND ALSO HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NOT
ONLY HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY. BUT
ALSO IN THE SENATE AS WELL WITH
RESPECT TO A NUMBER OF OTHERS
STATES WHO HAVE ALSO HAVE THIS
ON THE BOOKS INCLUDING INDIANA
KENTUCKY MISSISSIPPI NEBRASKA
NORTH CAROLINA OHIO SOUTH
CAROLINA UTAH VIRGINIA WEST
VIRGINIA THIS ENJOYS SUPPORT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
INCREASING CIVIC PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU MISTER LOS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER MALONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU TO
MY JOINT AUTHOR MEMBERS THE
TIME HAS FINALLY COME FOR
CALIFORNIA ONCE AND FOR ALL THE
JOIN. WITH SO MANY OTHER STATES
HAVE ALREADY DONE ALLOWING
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS TO VOTE IN
PRIMARY ELECTIONS OF THEY'LL BE
EIGHTEEN BY THE GENERAL. AFTER
SIXTEEN YEARS AND FIVE
DIFFERENT ATTEMPTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
OF. QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO VERIFY. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. AND THE CAR FIFTY FOUR
ALL MEMBERS VERY VOTE. THE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS IF THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
ITEM SB THREE HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL THREE
HUNDRED BY SENATOR ON BERGEN
AND RELATING TO ELECTIONS AND
CALLING ELECTIONS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MR BERMAN ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL THREE
HUNDRED WILL ENSURE THAT TO
MEASURES THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
A CA FOR AN ACA ELEVEN ARE ABLE
TO APPEAR ON THIS NOVEMBER'S
PRESIDENTIAL GENERAL ELECTION
BALLOT WITHOUT THIS BILL THOSE
MEASURES LIKELY WOULD NOT
APPEAR ON THE BALLOT UNTIL THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO STATEWIDE
PRIMARY ELECTION. IN THE PAST
THE LEGISLATURE OCCASIONALLY
HAS WAVE THE DEADLINE FOR
LEGISLATIVE MEASURES TO APPEAR
ON THE BALLOT WHERE
CIRCUMSTANCES WARRANT IN FACT
THE ASSEMBLY YOU WAVE TO THE
SAME DEADLINE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FOR A SENATE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. AND
WE DID SO BY A SEVENTY SIX TWO
ZERO VOTE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE AND HOW
THE VOTE I FIFTY THREE NO THIRD.
AT. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THERE.
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. YEAH
HI. WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
YOU VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
THIRTEEN ON THE OR DISEASE FIVE
FIFTY SIX NO THIRTEEN ON THE
MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX IN
ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY THREE TO
WITHDRAW ESPYS NINETY EIGHT
MONTH SIXTEEN SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW. FROM
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
SOME ERROR TEAM TO TAKE UP
THOSE BILLS TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIRD RE. AND I'M GONNA GO
AND. OKAY WELL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED WE HAVE. THEM AND I
FOR OLD. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE THIS THE FIRST. VOTE
MISTER. CALLED MOVES AND- BONTA.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRED
VOTE THIS IS PROCEDURAL MR
CALLED IS ASK FOR AN I. VOTE
MISTER FLOOR. IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESERTED THIS IS A PRETTY VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE I FIFTIES KNOWS FIFTH THE
MOTION PASSES. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO FIVE.
MEMBERS WE CAN
ENTERTAIN VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME IF ANYONE HAS A VOTE
CHANGE YOU CAN GO TO THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE YOUR DEATH. MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I MEN'S BIGGER OUT.
FILE TWENTY. AB EIGHTY THREE NO
TWO IN HIGH. BEAU CHANGE
PATTERSON ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
THREE NO TO I'D- THE BIGELOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR A CHANGE
SB THREE HUNDRED I TO KNOW.
BIGELOW SENATE BILL THREE
HUNDRED ODD TO KNOW. IT'S
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR A CHANGE AB AND NINETY TWO.
FROM I TO NOT VOTING. IN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
SOME PEOPLE NINETY TWO I TO NOT
VOTING.
MEMBERS BACK ON THE
FILE WE ARE GOING TO GO TO. SB
NINETY EIGHT WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL NINETY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE EDUCATION
FINANCE MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
OF FOUR STICK THE COMMUTER
LIEBER RELATED TO THE BUS BILL.
MISTER KING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB
NINETY EIGHT IS OUR K<c.cyan></c>
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
TRAILER BILL THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES. ALMOST SEVENTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND FUNDING TO PROP NINETY
EIGHT. ALSO HOLDS SCHOOLS
HARMLESS WHO- IT REALLY HELPS
SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WITH THE CROWNING ROMAN HOLDEN
HARMLESS GOING INTO NEXT YEAR
TO MAKE SURE THAT ADEQUATE
FUNDING TO EDUCATE OTHER
STUDENTS AND TO DEAL WITH. A
VARIETY OF ISSUES GOING INTO
THE SCHOOL YEAR ALSO
APPROPRIATE SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL K. THROUGH
TWELVE EIGHT FROM LEARNING LOS.
THAT'S A SPUR EDUCATION FUNDING
FORMULA. TAX TEACHERS ACROSS BE.
CUSTODIAL TRANSFER WORKERS LAY.
PROVIDES A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CHILD CARE
TRIGGER TO BOOST SERVICES FROM
FEDERAL FUTURE FUTURE FEDERAL
INTEREST RECEIVED. NOT TRANSIT
OF THE CHILD THE FOR THE OF
SOLAR SERVICES WITHOUT A
RESPECT ME AT FIVE. THANK YOU
MISS KING OVER NO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER I IN
OUR TO NOW EIGHT THIS TRAILER.
IMPLEMENTS OVERLAY THE BILL
DOLLAR YEAH CAGE TO. SO WERE
TELLING SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY
SHOULD DIP INTO THEIR RESERVES
STRUGGLE TO MAKE ENDS MEET THIS
YEAR SO THAT WE CAN PAY THEM A
LITTLE BIT IN THE NEXT YEAR AND
HOWEVER. THAT THIS YEAR'S BILLS
ARE ACTUALLY NEXT YEAR'S BILLS
COLLEAGUES THAT IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE WAY THE BILL ABOUT.
THIS TRAILER ALLOCATE. SEVERAL
DOLLARS IN CROWN OF OUR RELIEF
AND IT LOSE CERTAIN TO OF CAL
CHOI SCHOOL FOR THOSE ALLOCATE.
I'M A BELIEVER THAT FUN SHOULD
FOR THIS WORKS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY CHOOSE WELL ABOVE
WHERE THEY CHOOSE TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND THESE PARTICULAR
SCHOOLS SERVE SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO SERVE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THOSE WITH SERIOUS
LEARNING DISABILITIES FOR THAT
REASON I ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER
FONG RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. I THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE
REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN SEVEN SB NINETY EIGHT.
THIS BILL INCLUDES TROUBLING
PROVISIONS THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THIS
BILL AUTHORIZES BILLIONS IN
ONGOING DEFERRALS WITH
UNCERTAIN ONE TIME RELIEF.
BASED ON THE DEFERRAL SCHEDULE
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES MAY
NOT RECEIVE. ANY STATE A POOR
UNFORTUNATE FUNDING FOR FIVE
MONTHS FROM FEBRUARY THROUGH
JUNE. THIS BILL ALSO EXCLUDES
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND STATE SPECIAL
SCHOOLS FOR THE DEAF AND BLIND.
FOR MORE THAN FOUR POINT FIVE
BILLION IN STATE AND FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS REALLY FUNDING. IT
ALSO EXCLUDES NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY NEEDS DURING
KOBE NINETEEN CLOSURE PERIOD.
THIS BILL ALL AFFECTS HER
SCHOOL IN THE WAY THEY HAVE THE
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS AS AND ROLL
GROWTH. THEY'LL SEE FUNDING
LIMITED BECAUSE THEY CAPS THERE
WERE CAN IN THIS BILL EITHER
TWENTY NINTH TWENTY LEVEL WHICH
MAY THAT SUCCESS. CHARTER
SCHOOLS WILL BE NEGATIVELY.
PARENTS AND- IN MY JUST. WILL
FEEL REAL BECAUSE- BECAUSE OF
THIS BILL FOR THOSE REASONS I
ASK KNOW ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER DONALD ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE RICH. NOTHING
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THIS BILL
PROTECT. K. TWELVE FOR AND THE
IS A GOOD REASON TO SUPPORT IT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND I THANK THE CHAIR AND MANY
OTHERS IN THIS ROOM IN THIS
BILL. SEVEN DID YOU EVER THEY
CAN TO RE OPEN THIS FALL WHAT
THERE IS CONFUSION IN THIS
TRAILER BILL ON WHETHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE ALL THE BILL ALL
AVAILABLE MEANS TO SAFELY RE
OPEN SOME MAY HAVE STUDENTS IN
SCHOOL SOME MAY HAVE STUDENTS
ONLINE SOME MAY HAVE STUDENTS
IN SCHOOL AND ONLINE THEY MAY
HAVE TO GO TO A HYBRID MODEL
FOR- STUDENT HEALTH AND SAFETY
REASONS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD FROM
YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT THEY
ARE NOT SURE DISTRICTS LEARNING
AS ALLOWED PER THIS BILL.
BECAUSE OF THE LANGUAGE AND SB
NINETY EIGHT IS SOMEWHAT
RESTRICTIVE. AND DEFINITELY NOT
CLEAR FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. SO
VERY SIMPLY I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO REVISIT THIS- IN A
SUBSEQUENT TRAILER BILL TO
CLARIFY. THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO ONLINE
IN A VERY RAPID FASHION OR
CREATE SOME HYBRID MODEL AND A
VERY RAPID FASHION. SHOULD THEY
NEED TO DO THAT FOR STUDENT
HEALTH AND SAFETY REASONS BUT-
THE FIRST PRIORITY SHOULD BE TO
GET. OUR CHILDREN. BACK IN
SCHOOL AT A SCHOOL SITE BUT
CERTAINLY WITH THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY IN MIND AND FOLLOWING
ALL. STATE AND LOCAL GUIDANCE
SO WITH THAT I TURNED IT BACK
TO YOU MATTERS. THANK YOU
MISTER O'DONNELL. THIS VALUE
ARE. IN REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I WRI IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY AB
SEVENTY SEVEN THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT
CAP KATE TWELVE AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE AT TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY LEVELS WILL
UNFAIRLY PUNISHED SCHOOLS THAT
OPERATE SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS AND
ATTRACTED NEWS STERN STUDENTS
DURING CODE NINETEEN. MANY OF
WHICH WILL LIKELY BE CHARTER
SCHOOLS SO PARENTS HAVE
RESEARCHED AND FOUND THE BEST
SCHOOL OPTION FOR THEIR CHILD
DURING THIS PANDEMIC THE SCHOOL
OF THEIR CHOICE WILL NOT
RECEIVE THE EIGHTY EIGHT TO
COVER THE COST OF EDUCATING
THEIR CHILD. IN A TIME WHEN
FAMILIES ARE SCRAMBLING TO ME
THAT THEIR CHILD RECEIVES A
QUALITY EDUCATION AB SEVENTY
SEVEN SERIOUSLY UNDERMINE THIS
GOAL THIS IS UNFAIR ABOUT
STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS AND I
STRONGLY URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER WITH LIMóN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR THAT.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU SPEAKER
AND MEMBER. WE ALL KNOW THE
THIS IS A- TO BY HAND FOR MAY
OF US IT'S THE FOR BUDGET WE
VOTE ON DURING A RECESSION. I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF THE
WORK OF ALL OF THOSE INVOLVED
INCLUDING OUR BUDGET CHAIR AND
SAID CHAIR. ON THESE ISSUES. I
AM SUPPORTING TODAY'S BUDGET
AND DO SO KNOWING THAT THERE
ARE DIFFICULTIES AND CHALLENGES
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN SB
NINETY EIGHT. OUR CALLED MY
COLLEAGUES EVERY ISSUES RELATED
TO THE HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION.
FOR NOT JUST CHARTER SCHOOLS
BUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS A LIKE. I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT AS A
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
THESE CHALLENGES IMPACT THE
LOCALS AND A VERY REAL WAY.
THEY IMPLY ENROLLMENT. EDDIE
NOW. AND MUCH MORE.
ADDITIONALLY ALL SCHOOLS HAVE
TAKEN ON RESPONSIBILITIES
BEYOND WHAT THEY WERE DOING
TAKE AND HAVE COMPLETELY
CHANGED THE WAY THAT THEY
PROVIDE EDUCATION WE KNOW THAT
IN THESE TIMES THEY NEED MORE
FUNDING NOT LESS WE'VE HEARD
FROM TEACHERS FROM SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS FROM SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND MANY MORE
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
UPON THEM. IN THIS VERY MOMENT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON
WAYS TO CORRECT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES WHILE RECOGNIZING THAT
THIS IS NOT A PERFECT BUDGET.
BUT IT ALSO MUST BE SAID. BUT
IF WE LOOK AT THE ME REVISED
AND LOOK WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN
THE MAY REVISE. THIS IS A
BETTER OPTIONS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WE PROPOSED IN THE
ME REVISED LARGER CUTS TO
CLASSROOMS WE PROPOSED A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF FUNDING
FORMULA AND WHILE THERE IS NO
EASY DECISIONS WE HAVE GOT TO
MOVE FORWARD IN A WAY THAT
HELPS SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE. THE IMPORTANCE OF
WHAT WE'VE DONE FOR CHILD CARE.
MANY IN THIS AND I KNOW THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS CHAMPION
CHILD CARE AND THIS IS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
YOU SEE IN THIS BUDGET OUR
ABILITY TO PROTECT. CHILD CARE
EVEN IN A TIME OF CRISIS. ONE
NOT PERFECT THIS BUDGET
PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION FOR CHILD CARE AND
MANY PROGRAMS ARE CONSTITUENTS
RELY ON I TO WANT MORE FROM
FUNDING AND I WANT TO SAVE MORE
PROGRAMS BUT I UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION THAT WE ARE FACING
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES WE MUST
PASS A BUDGET THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE AND IT PROTECTS ALL
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES EVEN IF
IT'S DIFFICULT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS THEM ON THIS
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL WITH THE CAVEA OF
COURSE- WELL IT. MAINTAINS
FUNDING FOR MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I HAVE AT LEAST ONE
RAPIDLY GROWING SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN MY DISTRICT IN MOUNTAIN
HOUSE. THAT WILL BE HARMED BY
THIS SO I KNOW THAT THEY'RE
STILL ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
GOING FORWARD AND I KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE ON THIS TODAY AND
FULL SUPPORT BECAUSE FOR THE
MOST PART. IT PRESERVES
EDUCATION ACROSS STATE A
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS WHO ARE PERFORMING
VERY WELL AND HAVERAPID GROWTH
I THINK WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
FIND SOME FIXES FOR THOSE AS
WELL AND I LOOK FOR THOSE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
SEGMENT MR GIVING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR. AND THE BUDGET
CHAIR FOR INCLUDING THE FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM DURING
CORPORATE NINETEEN THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS IS AN
EFFORT THAT I CHAMPION THROUGH
LEGISLATION AND IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION WAS A TONY
THURMOND. FOR FOOD IN
SECURITIES A LACK OF MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT AND IN ADEQUATE
HEALTHCARE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
BARRIERS TO. STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE CURRENTLY FACE ARE
FACING EXORBITANT- BY
EXACERBATING USUALLY BY THE
COLD AT NIGHT CRY. GIMME
SCHOOLS OFFER UNIQUE MODELS TO
ADDRESS THEIR HURDLES THROUGH
WRAPAROUND SERVICES INCREASING-
PARENT PARTICIPATION AND
ENGAGEMENT AND RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES. THIS IS ABOUT
QUALITY AND BEST SERVING THE
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY. THROUGH
BEST PRACTICES SPECULATE I ALSO
AYE VOTE ON A. NINETY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER GET SET
PATTERSON YOU ARE. AS. I
MANAGED MEMBERS I TO RISE WITH
GREAT CA IN AND- TO THIS BILL
FOR A COUPLE REASONS UP FIRST
OF ALL ALTHOUGH IT IS AND TO.
BETTER FUND SCHOOLS GENERAL. I
JUST DON'T THINK IT GOES FAR
ENOUGH AND I THINK AS OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE SUGGESTED THIS
LEAVE SOME- SCHOOL DISTRICT
REALLY OUT IN THE COLD. I ALSO
WANT TO RAISE AN OBJECTION OVER
UTILIZING. A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL TO ESSENTIALLY CARVE OUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM FAIR
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW. IT
THIS SHOULD HAVE ON THROUGH THE
NORMAL AN ORDINARY LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS I RAISE IT BECAUSE I
HAVE RECEIVED. DOZENS OF PLEASE
FROM PRINCIPLES PERRANCE SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN MY AREA. THERE IS NO
NEED TO PENALIZE CHARTER
SCHOOLS HERE. AND THIS IS A
VERY RECKLESS WAY OF DOING IT.
I POINT TO UNIVERSITY HIGH
SCHOOL IT IS ON THE CAMPUS OF
FRESNO STATE UNIVERSITY IT IS
ONE OF THE TOP CHARTER SCHOOLS
IN THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES
WINNING ACCOLADES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. FOR WHAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO DO WITH THE STUDENTS THAT
ATTEND. AND THIS TRAILER BILL
ESSENTIALLY SAYS THEY DON'T
COUNT. CARVE OUT. PENALIZED
THIS IS NOT FAIR LEGISLATION I
ASK THAT YOU EITHER LAY OFF OR
OPPOSE- FOR THE REASONS THAT
I'VE JUST SUGGESTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION- TO THIS BILL
CERTAINLY. WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR
AND I THINK IT IS LAUDABLE THAT
WE'VE INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY GOING INTO EDUCATION K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION IN
THIS BUDGET. CERTAINLY BETTER
THAN THE MAY REVISE. THAT WE
ALL SAW THAT WE WERE ALL
TALKING ABOUT ON THIS FLOOR WE
HAD THE COMMITTEE ON THE WHOLE.
THAT IS A BENEFIT BUT THE
FUNDAMENTAL THING THAT IS WRONG
WITH THIS TRAILER BILL IS THAT
IT TAKES AWAY FROM THE
PRINCIPLE THAT THE MONEY SHOULD
FOLLOW THE STUDENT. AND THE
REASON WHY WE DO THAT IS
BECAUSE IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT THE KIDS. IT IS SUPPOSED
TO BE ABOUT THE STUDENTS AND
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE GETTING.
WHAT THEY NEED. TO SUCCEED. AND
INSTEAD IT IT FREEZES THE
MONEY BASED ON EIGHTY A OF LAST
YEAR. SO REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THOSE WHERE THAT KID GOES. THE-MONEY'S FROZEN IT DOES NOT
FOLLOW HIM OR HER. AND WHAT IS
THAT WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT
SEND. TO THE STUDENTS AND THE
PARENTS OF THE STATE. IT SAYS
THAT IT IS MORE IMPORTANT FOR
US TO SHORE UP AND PROTECT THE
INSTITUTION. THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE INSTITUTION IN THE STATE
THEN IT IS TO LOOK OUT FOR THE
KIDS AND WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THOSE KIDS. AND
THAT HAS REALLY BEEN THE
CONTINUING PROBLEM WITH
EDUCATION IN THE STATE IS IN IT.
BECAUSE THAT'S AN INSTITUTION
THAT AS WE ALL KNOWN AS WE SAID
SEVERAL TIMES ON THIS FLOOR. IS
FAILING BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS IN THE STATE. THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS STILL SO
WIDE AND WE ARE NOT MAKING
PROGRESS. AND WE'RE GOING TO
SHORE UP THAT INSTITUTION TODAY
LAST LAST WEEK. WE MOVED
QUICKLY. TO ADDRESS PROP TWO OH
NINE HAD TO DO IT URGENT HAD TO
DO THIS TO ADDRESS THIS VITAL
ISSUE BUT TODAY ON THIS FLOOR
NOT URGENT TO ADDRESS THAT K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
PROBLEM THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP
LET'S JUST KEEP SHORING UP.
THIS INSTITUTION BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT IT'S MORE
IMPORTANT. THEN WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THOSE KIDS. MANY OF THOSE
KIDS ARE TRYING TO GET OUT OF
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT GETTING
THE JOB DONE. MANY OF THOSE.
pIN FRONT OF TEACHERS THAT WILL
ADDRESS. THOSE CONCERNS. BUT
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL TODAY
SAYS NOW. WE DON'T CARE IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE YOUR KIDS
SOMEWHERE ELSE WE DON'T CARE IF
YOU WANT TO GET A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOUR KID THE
MONEY'S NOT GOING TO FALL ON.
IT'S GOING TO STAY IN THE
INSTITUTION. I THINK WE REALLY
NEED TO SERIOUSLY CHECK
OURSELVES WITH THIS WHY WOULD
YOU PUT THAT IN THERE WHY WOULD
YOU CHANGE THE ROLE. THIS SAYS
THE MONEY SHOULD FALL THE
STUDNTS THERE IS NO OTHER
REASON FOLKS. YOU VOTE FOR THIS
YOU'RE VOTING FOR AN
INSTITUTION THAT IS FAILING OUR
KIDS. WE CAN DO BETTER. WE CAN
AND WE SHOULD DO BETTER. I URGE
YOU TO REJECT THIS BILL OR AT
LEAST STAY OFF OF IT. AND LET'S
GET SOMETHING BETTER FOR OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINETY EIGHT. AND I DON'T
TAKE THAT LIGHTLY. BUT I FEEL
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO. DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR OUR KIDS. AND
THAT WAS RIGHT FOR OUR KIDS
SHOULD NOT BE A PARTY ISSUE. I
HAVE SEVERAL PROBLEMS. WITH
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL. FIRST
OF ALL I WANNA AGAIN
ACKNOWLEDGE. THE WORK OF THE
BUDGET CHAIR AND THOSE THAT
MADE SURE THAT ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WOULD RECEIVE MORE
MONIES THAN THEIR RECEIVING
THIS YEAR AND CERTAINLY MORE
THAN WHAT THEY WOULD BEEN
RECEIVING ARE THE NAY REVISE I
DO APPRECIATE THAT. BUT THIS IS.
A MULTI YEAR EFFORT THERE WERE
ENGAGING IN TO PROVIDE THE BEST
EDUCATION FOR OUR KIDS AND WE
ARE TAKING AWAY A- SEE THE
NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY. THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND FAMILIES
NEED TO BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH
THIS COVER NINETY NINETEEN
REALITY. YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL.
THERE ARE. THESE VAGUE AND
UNCLEAR MANDATES ON DISTANCE
LEARNING THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT
SHOULD. HAVE BEEN VETTED FULLY
VETTED THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IT SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
PART OF THIS BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. YOU KNOW AND THIS IS
PERSONAL FOR ME AND FOR MANY OF
US. YOU KNOW. MY WIFE AND I AS
PARENTS. WHERE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH THE
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER WE WERE
GOING TO FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
OUR DAUGHTER GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL IN THE FALL YOU KNOW
THERE'S SO MUCH UNKNOWN ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
THIS VIRUS YOU KNOW WITH ANY
VACCINE OR TREATMENT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANYTHING BY THE FALL AND YET
THIS. BUDGET TRAILER HAS
LANGUAGE THAT IS IT- TELLING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT THEY NEED
TO DO YOU KNOW EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO GET THE KIDS BACK
IN THE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW UNLESS
THEIR ORDERS FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER OR UNLESS THE
CHILD IS MEDICALLY VULNERABLE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE SOME. YOU KNOW
ONGOING EFFORTS THE THAT THE
CHAIR OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. INDICATED THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE FURTHER WORK ON
THIS THAT THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE IN
EDUCATION FUNDING INDICATED
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE. YOU
KNOW OUT OF A LETTER. TO TRY
TO- CLARIFY SOME OF THESE
UNCLEAR MANDATES BUT AGAIN I
MEAN WE SHOULD HAVE HAD A FULL
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN THESE
REAL ISSUES ABOUT DISTANCE
LEARNING RATHER THAN HAVING
THIS RAM THROUGH US. THROUGH
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL SO I
OBJECT TO THIS BEING IN THE
BUDGET TRAILER. SECOND OF ALL.
YOU KNOW WE NEED TO GIVE
FAMILIES THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DEAL WITH COVERT NINETEEN AND I
HAVE TO SAY. I AGREE WITH MANY
OF MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
THAT ARE GETTING UP TO TALK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW HOW THIS IS
UNFAIRLY CAPPING. THE
ENROLLMENT OF SCHOOLS THAT
FAMILIES ARE TURNING TO DEAL
WITH THIS CUP IN NINETEEN
REALITY. YOU KNOW I I'VE I'VE
HEARD FROM SEVERAL MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT ARE THEY
TALKING ABOUT HOW THEY HAVE
ELDERLY IN THE HOUSEHOLD THEY
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY THAT
ARE. IMMUNE COMPROMISED. AND NO
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THIS THIS COVER NINETEEN
REALITY AND WE NEED THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO- YOU
KNOW. DO WHAT'S BEST FOR KIDS.
AND IN OUR IN OUR FAMILIES AND
TO CAP THE ENROLLMENT OF SOME
OF THESE- NON CLASSROOM
CHARTERS THAT THAT FAMILIES ARE
TURNING TO YOU KNOW AS THEIR
BEST OPTION AFTER SURVEYING ALL
THE OPTIONS YOU KNOW MAKING
HARD DECISIONS. WE CAN'T TAKE
AWAY THAT FLEXIBILITY FROM THE
FAMILIES ARE TRYING TO THE
RIGHT THINGS FOR THEIR KIDS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND SO. AGAIN I
DON'T TAKE THIS LIGHTLY BUT- WE
NEED TO DO WHAT'S BEST FOR OUR
KIDS TO DEAL WITH THIS COVER
NINETEEN REALITY AND FOR THAT
REASON I'LL BE VOTING NO ON SB
NINETY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
MESSAGE TO KILEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I RISE IN OPPOSITION
THIS BILL CONTAINS PROFOUND
CHANGES TO EDUCATION FINANCE
THAT WERE DROPPED AT THE
ELEVENTH HOUR OUT OF THE BLUE-
WITHOUT ANY PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION- OR ANY PROCESS
AS ONE OF THE ADVOCATES FOR THE
TYPES OF SCHOOLS THAT'LL BE
MOST NEGATIVELY IMPACTED PUT IT
IN MY THIRTY YEARS OF CLOSE
INVOLVEMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUDGET PROCESS. I'VE
NEVER WITNESSED SUCH AN
EGREGIOUS ABUSE. SO WHY IS IT
THAT SCHOOLS GROW WHAT COULD BE
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITES ARE
GROWING. AND IT'S ALSO BECAUSE
THEY'RE DOING A GOOD JOB. AND
THAT'S PARTICULARLY TRUE. OF
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
ASSIGNED TO STUDENTS BY THE
DEFAULT OF THE ZIP CODE. BUT
HAVE TO ATTRACT THEM TO OFTEN
THROUGH A DESIRABLE PRODUCT AND
THAT THE SAP OF OUR PUBLIC AT.
SYSTEM THAT WE CALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THIS HAPPENS TO BE THE
SECTOR THAT HAS PIONEERED THE
MODELS OF DISTANCE LEARNING.
THAT HAVE PROVEN TO BE OF SUCH
ABOUT. SO WHAT'S THE PRACTICAL
IMPACT OF THIS WILL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF JOHN ADAMS WHICH IS
A- FEW SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY OPERATE CAMPUSES IN EL
DORADO HILLS LINCOLN IN
ROSEVILLE THAT SERVE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE STUDENTS THIS LAST YEAR. AS
OF TODAY JOHN ADAMS IS ALREADY
ENROLLED EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE NEW STUDENTS
ACROSS THREE CAMPUSES FOR THE
COMING SCHOOL YEAR. THEY'VE
HIRED THIRTY NINE NEW
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS AND
TWELVE ADDITIONAL STAFF TO
SUPPORT THIS GROWTH IN
ENROLLMENT IF THIS BILL BECOMES
LAW JOHN ADAMS WILL ROUTE LOSE
AROUND EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING AND WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE ENROLLMENT
OF THESE NEW STUDENTS. WILL
ALSO BE UNABLE TO RETAIN THE
FIFTY ONE NEWLY HIRED TEACHERS
AND STAFF WHO THEN BE LEFT
WITHOUT EMPLOYMENT AT A TIME
WHEN MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
ARE STRUGGLING TO STAY AFLOAT
FINANCIALLY. THE SAME IS TRUE
OF MANY DISTRICTS THE ROSE BOWL
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT- WHICH IS ALSO IN MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. IS PROJECTED
TO HAVE THREE HUNDRED NEW
STUDENTS THIS COMING YEAR HAS
ALREADY HIRED STAFF. AND THIS
BILL LEAVE THEM WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES. THAT THEY NEED SO
HOW DOES THIS MAKE ANY SENSE.
WHY WHY DO THESE PROVISIONS
EXIST. WELL MAYBE ONE CLUE
COMES IN THE COMMUNITY THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED- WITH
THIS BILL AND EXCLUDED FROM.
CORONA VIRUS I RELIEF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF IT AND THAT'S THE
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHICH IS SEVERAL PEOPLE
OF SAID ARE- SCHOOLS THAT MANY
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. HAVE
BEEN TURNING TO. AGAIN AND
AGAIN TIME AFTER TIME. WE'VE
HAD BILLS THAT TARGET THIS
COMMUNITY. THIS LEGISLATION
ONLY MAKES SENSE IN LIGHT OF
THAT INVIDIOUS PATTERN OF
DISCRIMINATION. I MEAN THE
PARENTS AND FAMILIES AND SCHOOL
LEADERS AND TEACHERS AND
EVERYONE ELSE WHO ARE PART OF
THIS COMMUNITY THEY LOOK UPON
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT WITH
NOTHING BUT FEAR. THIS WONDER
WHAT NEXT. WHAT HARM IS GONNA
BE DONE TO ME IN MY SCHOOL AND
MY WAY OF LIFE. FROM THE
RAREFIED PROCEEDINGS. OF THIS
CHAMBER. THAT'S A DYNAMIC THAT
SHOULD NEVER EXISTING MODERN
LIBERAL DEMOCRACY. YEAH THIS
BILL INTENSIFIES IT LIKE NEVER
BEFORE I'M ASKING YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE NO. THANK YOU MISTER KILEY
A MISTER RICARDO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I WANT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT CAME UP. BUT
THE BIG PICTURE IS LOOK WHEN WE
ALL RAN FOR OFFICE THE NUMBER
ONE THING THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
I'M SURE IS EDUCATION. OUR KIDS
ARE YOU WE TALKED ABOUT THE
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL
IN THE BUDGET WE SAID THE
NUMBER ONE THING WE WANT TO
ADDRESS IS OUR SCHOOLS FROM
EARLY EDUCATION THROUGH COLLEGE
IN K. TWELVE IN THE MIDDLE. AND
THIS BILL DOES THAT TO THE BEST
OF OUR ABILITY SURE THE
DEFERRALS ARE THE OPTIMAL WAY
TO GO BUT IF YOU ASK THE SCHOOL
THIS WOULD RATHER TAKE A
DEFERRAL DEFERRING. YOUR CASH
FOR A FEW MONTHS OR AN EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR HIT TO SCHOOL
FUNDING. THEY WOULD TAKE THE
PEARLS THERE IS NO- TOOTH FAIRY
HERE HANDING OUT MONEY AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO DEFERRAL SO
LET'S HAVE A REALITY CHECK
THEIR- DODD AS NOTED BUT- BY.
MY COLLEAGUE SANTA BY. FROM THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. THIS BUDGET
MADE TO RE PRIORITIZE FUNDING
FOR OUR SCHOOLS BUT ALSO EARLY
EDUCATION BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
TURN BACK ON THE ECONOMY. YOU
CAN'T GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
UNLESS YOU FULLY FIND. EARLY
EDUCATION AND WE KNOW CHILD
CARE CENTERS. ARE REALLY I'M
DYING AT THE VINE AS FAR AS
INADEQUATE FUNDING. AND
PERMISSION TO READ REAL QUICK
MADAM SPEAKER. WITHOUT
OBJECTION JUST A HEADLINE TODAY
JUST READ A FEW MOMENTS AGO.
SAYS TODAY'S HEADLINES FROM
POLITICO A LACK OF CHILD CARE
IS KEEPING WOMEN ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT ROLLS WOMEN'S
PARTICIPATION THE WORK FORCE
WAS QUITE THE CLOSELY TIED TO
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE HAS DROPPED
AT A FASTER CLIP. THAN MEN
SINCE THE EARLY SPRING SO WE
KNOW IT'S SIMPLE MATHEMATICS IS
ONLY SO MANY CHILD CARE
CENTERS. THAT ARE SERVING KIDS
RIGHT NOW IF WE DON'T PROBABLY
FIND THEM PEOPLE CAN'T GO BACK
TO WORK SO ONE OF THE GREAT
ELEMENTS OF THIS BUDGET IS WE
PRE ALLOCATE MONIES ARE GOING
TO GET FROM THE NEXT ROUND OF
KERR'S ACT. TO BOLSTER UP OUR
CHILD CARE EXPERIENCE LOTS AND
PROVIDE STIPENDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE CENTERS FINANCIALLY
PENCIL OUT. AS FAR AS THE
ISSUES FOR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS I
WANT ADDRESS THIS WHOLE EIGHTY
A THING. BECAUSE REALLY IT'S A
FALLACY THAT WERE HARMING. ONE
PARTICULAR TYPE OF SCHOOL
THAT'S NOT TRUE. MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SACRAMENTO THE
THOMAS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
FACE A BIT OF A HIT TO BECAUSE
THERE ARE GROWING DISTRICT IT'S
NOT ABOUT. ANTI CHARTER SCHOOLS
IT'S ABOUT HOW MANY STUDENTS
YOU HAVE IN THE SCHOOL TODAY.
SO REALLY THIS IS A TRADE OFF
WE WANT HELP NINETY PERCENT. OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS STAY
AFLOAT. AND HAVE A TEMPORARY
HICK UP 410% FOR ONE YEAR
DURING THIS HOLD HARMLESS
EIGHTY EIGHT. NOW TO TRADE UP
WE HAD TO MAKE WE CAN UNDO
THIS. BUT WE HAVE TO GO DO MORE
DEFERRALS ARE DIP INTO THE TO
THE RAINY DAY FUND IS ONLY SO
MUCH MONEY THAT GOES AROUND SO
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS HARMS. ONE
TYPE OF SCHOOL I WILL SAY WE
HEAR THIS LOUD AND CLEAR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON TALKED
ABOUT A DISTRICT IN HER AREA
THAT'S DOUBLED IN POPULATION
LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF A NEW.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THIS IS
AROUND THE DATE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS WE HAD A HEARING THIS
MORNING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SAID THERE AWARE OF IT.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THAT WE-
KEEP THE SCHOOLS OF. MY MONEY
THIS ISSUE IN THE TIME MONTHS.
THE ISSUE THE DISTANCE LEARN
AND THE LACK OF CLARITY. WE
BROUGHT THIS UP MORNING IN THIS.
AND UPS THE PHONE BUDGET CAN
JUST. AND THEY'LL ORDER TO
ADDRESS THIS WE ARE GOING TO
SEE. A LETTER TO THE JOURNAL
CLARIFYING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS. A LANGUAGE IN SB
NINETY EIGHT RELATED DISTANCE
LEARNING. THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS OF SARS WHAT AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT RECEIVES. UP
THAT A NUMBER OF PARENTS TO SAY
HEY I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE CLASS AND I WANT TO BE
FULLY. ONLINE DISTANCE LEARNING
WITH THE BE PROHIBITED FROM
DOING THAT- THAT'S NOT
CERTAINLY THE INTENT. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE CLARIFIED THAT
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL ABOUT
THAT AS WELL. THERE'S ALSO
GOING TO BE ALERT TO THAT
YOU'RE NOT RELATED TO LAY OFF
THERE IS SOME CONFUSION ABOUT
LAYOFFS DURING THIS. A COVERT
NINETEEN IN A TIME PERIOD SEE
THE NEXT. DAYS LASTLY. AS FAR
AS- HIGHER EDUCATION THIS. MAKE
SURE WE KEEP OUR UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS A FULL OUT IF WE GET
FEDERAL FUNDING WHICH WE ARE
VERY OPTIMISTIC WILL HAPPEN YOU
SEE AND SO YOU STILL GET A 5%
INCREASE OVER LAST YEAR'S
FUNDING FOR UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WE FULLY FUND ARE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM WE REALIZE THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE WORK
COURSE OF OUR OUR OUR HIGHER
IT'S SYSTEM WE MAKE SURE WE
FULLY FUND THE APPORTIONMENT
AND KEEP GOING THAT WITH OUR
COMMUNITY CALLED SYSTEM- WITH
THAT OVERALL THIS WASN'T A
PERFECT SITUATION BUT IS WAY
WAY BETTER THAN WE HAD NAY. AND
THE SCHOOL THIS IS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ARE EMBRACING THE
PLAN WE HAVE BEFORE THAT BEFORE
US TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MATTERS MEMBERS
I'D RISE IN GREAT HAS A TWO.
AND WE- IN SUPPORT AS WE-
NINETY EIGHT. I KNOW IT'S THE
TO CREATE A BUT- AND IT'S AN
AND I KNOW HOW HARD IT IS WHEN
YOU'VE GOT SO MANY FACTORS.
FACTIONS FIGHTING FOR THE
NICKELS AND DIMES AT A BEER- I
THINK THIS IS MUCH BETTER THAN
WHAT WE HAD WHEN WE STARTED IN
MAY. BUT LIKE MOST OF US
REALIZE IT'S NOT ENOUGH. AND
WE'VE LEFT OUT SOME IMPORTANT
PEOPLE IN THE PROCESS- I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THOSE OF YOU WHO
HAVE RAISED THE ISSUE. ABOUT
UNDERPERFORMING SCHOOLS AN
UNDERPERFORMING CHILDREN AND
WHAT NEEDS TO DO THAT YOU WILL
KEEP THAT PASSION. THE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND AS AS
YOU LOOK AT YOUR LEGISLATION
AND AS YOU FIGHT FOR THE THINGS
THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT- IT IS
PAINFUL TO ME TO HAVE ANY CHILD
NOT. ACTUALLY FUNDED. BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME REALLY
WONDERFUL SCHOOLS THAT ARE
WORKING VERY HARD. AND HAVE
ATTRACTED STUDENTS TO THOSE
SCHOOLS AND WILL NOT GET THE
FUNDING NECESSARY TO MOVE
FORWARD. WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE
THEM WHEN IT COMES TO AUGUST.
IN SEPTEMBER IF WE HAVE
RESOURCES LEFT OVER. WE MUST
MAINTAIN THAT FOCUS THAT'S
THERE. YOU'RE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT WE ARE. WHEN I THERE
IS A IT. LIKE THE FIRST THING
WE DO IS WE TALK ABOUT IT SHE
BEGAN. WE TALKED ALL THOSE KIDS
ARE BEHIND. AND YET I. COMPASS
MAYBE NOW WITH EVERY BUT WITH.
MAJORITY YOU RE. CONCERNING THE
MY THAT WOULD FOR. BAY LEARNING.
AND EVERYBODY. THAT THEY DID
NOT SAY THAT'S GO TO THE KID
WHO REALLY HAVE THE LEARNING
LOS. THE ONES WHO ARE BEHIND
THE ONES WHO WE KNOW HAVE NOT.
TURNED ON THEIR THEIR THEIR
REPORT THEIR COMPUTERS TO
LEARN- AND NOT NECESSARILY
GIVEN TO THE KIDS. THAT HAVE
DOING QUITE WELL BUT EVERYBODY
WANTED THAT MONEY. EVERYBODY
WAS THAT MONEY. AND SO AS A
RESULT NO ONE WAS WILLING TO
SACRIFICE. TO BASICALLY TAKE
THAT MONEY THAT CAME IN FROM
OVER. TO TALK ABOUT LEARNING
LOSS. AND PUT IT IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY HAVE THE
GREATEST AMOUNT OF LOS. BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WANTED AT THAT TIME.
SO WHAT I HEAR YOU TELL ME
ABOUT CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP. MAKING SURE THAT EVERY KID
HAS WHAT THEY NEED IN TERMS OF
WHERE THEY ARE. I KNOW THAT IS
SOMETIMES JUST EMPTY RHETORIC.
BECAUSE THEN WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO THE CUTTING UP. AND THE
THINGS THAT ARE DIVVIED UP.
THOSE KIDS STILL DON'T HAVE A
VOICE IN ON THIS HOUSE THE
THINGS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN. SO
I JUST WANT TO CHALLENGE YOU TO
BASICALLY. KEEP THAT. GOING
KEEP YOUR COMMITMENT. REALIZING
THAT WHEN YOU MAKE THOSE
COMMITMENTS YOU ALSO HAVE TO
MAKE THE FINANCIAL INVESTMENT
AS WELL. AND SOMETIMES YOU HAVE
TO LOSE SOMETHING. IN ORDER TO
GET WHERE WE WANT TO GO. WE
HAVE NEVER PRIORITIZE KIDS WILL
BE FINE IN THIS HOUSE. THAT I
HAVE SEEN. WE TALK ABOUT IT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO TALK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY. CHANGING OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM NOTHING NEEDED
TO. WE GET WE GET WE GET ALL OF
THE PLACE WITH WHERE WE TO BE.
WE CAN FIVE EVERY. IN FELL.
THEN THE EDUCATE. AFTER WE
BASICALLY GIVE OF DO THINGS. A
UNIQUE AND REVOLUTIONARY. WILL
NOT BE WITH THE MOST CRITICAL
IN. FACING CALIFORNIA AND IS
NOT COLD IT IT IS. EVERY IN QUE.
TO THE MAXIMUM. AND WE HAVE
HAVE GIVEN UP ON THAT SO MANY
WAYS. SO I'M I'M- IT'S POINT AT
THE HOUSE WHEN A PLAN. TO
REALLY BROUGH CAL. EDGE FORWARD.
I'VE TALKED MANY OF YOU EDUCATE
ME SAY WE ALL DO IT. WHICH KNOW
OUR HEART OF TO DO BE YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE TO. THE MY- AND MANY
OF YOU DON'T WANT TO FIGHT
THOSE MONSTERS. THOSE LITTLE.
THOSE GROUPS THAT HOLD YOU
TIGHT. AND SO AS A RESULT WE'VE
BEEN. BASICALLY DO WE HAVE TO
DO. SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S THE BEST
WE CAN GET AT THIS POINT. IN
TERMS OF US MOVING FORWARD BUT
I HOPE YOU DON'T FORGET. AND I
HOPE YOU HOLD TIGHT TO IT.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME I WE WILL
FOR BY JUMPED OVER THE BUT WHAT
BY KATE. WHAT IS PROP TWO OH
NINE. WELL ABOUT K. TWELVE. I
FIGHT WILL CLICK TWELVE AND YUP
WE TOGETHER AND THE BY. LINE IS
THIS. SO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
NOW. AND TRY TO THROW. THE
OTHER CASE ARMY I'M NOT LIST
BECAUSE I WHEN RUN MEETS THE-
YOU'RE NOT THERE. OF THE TIME.
IF SO WANT YOU TO UNDER. THAT
THIS THERE SHOULD BE A MOVE.
ABOUT IT IS AND OUR CHILDREN
THAT ARE IN THIS DAY. BUT I'M
NOT GETTING THE RE. THEY NEED.
AND IF FOLKS OF TO THIS. THAT
ARE SIX. WE NEED TO ASK HER.
WHY NOT KILL THEM ALL. BUT
BASICALLY MIMICKED THE WHEN A
LEARNED THEIR SIX. SO I SAY
THIS A DAY BECAUSE- IS MUST. NO
YOU THINK. NOT ALSO IN OTHERS I
CARE ALL THOSE THINGS AND- JEFF
ISSUE. BUT I KNOW THAT WE RUN A
FROM TWELVE AT. EVERY TIME WE A
CHANCE. TO MAKE SYSTEMIC. REAL
THAT WILL ENSURE THE AT THE OF
EVERY. SO I'VE YOU YOU'LL VOTE
CONTRA TODAY I'M OPEN EIGHT
BECAUSE IS WHAT THE- WE GO GET
IT THIS MOMENT. BUT YOU SHOULD
NOT BE UP ON THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE NOT DONE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO. AND THE SHOULD BE ORGAN.
MAY EDUCATE A PRIDE. IN THIS
HOUSE. TO MOVE FOR TO CHANGE
EDUCATION THE KIDS OF. ALL
MEMBERS THAT HE STARTED THE.
BURKE WILL FLOWS THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY FOUR NO
SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
ZERO YEP. MOVING TO AT. SB ONE
SIXTEEN WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL ONE SIXTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION OF FOUR STICK
FIGURE IMMEDIATELY RELATED TO
THE BUDGET SEARCHING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SP ONE SIXTEEN IS OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER BILL
THIS IS THE CAL GRANT AMOUNT AT
NINE THOUSAND EIGHTY FOUR FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. DURING THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ACADEMIC YEAR PROVIDES FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID FOR AB FIVE FORTY
STUDENTS WITH A ONE TIMEBLOCK
GRANT TO HELP COMMUNICATE IS
OVER COVERED NINETEEN COSTS AND
IMPROVE DISTANCE EDUCATION WITH
ITEMS PROFESS RIVAL FOR SB ONE
SIXTEEN THANK YOU MISTER CHANG
WITH URBAN ALLTO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED LETTER SPEAKER RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTEEN AT
THIS TRAILER BILL IMPLEMENTS
NECESSARY FUNDING AND CHANGES
TO. CALIFORNIA PER SEASON WHICH
IS WHETHER THE FACTS OF THE
CURRENT EPIDEMIC IN THE CURRENT
REESSION THESE CHANGES ARE
NECESSARY AND ALTHOUGH I OBJECT
TO THE USE OF ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS OF DEFERRALS IN
THIS BUDGET- THIS DOES HELP
THESE UNIVERSITIES WHETHER THE
EFFECTS. OF THE RECESSION ARJUN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE SEEING IN HEARING NO
FURTHER. ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY THERE
TO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT I SEVENTY
KNOWS HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION ALL ASSEMBLY
BILLS PASSED TODAY WILL BE
IMMEDIATELY ORDERED TO
ENROLLMENT AND ALL SENATE BILLS
PASSED TODAY WILL BE
IMMEDIATELY TRANSMITTED TO THE
SENATE.
NINE BERMAN AROUND.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO THE DAILY FILE FILE
ITEM THREE AC A ELEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSUME THE
CONSTITUTION LIMITED ELEVEN BY
SOME MEMORABLE ANOTHER CYNICAL
IN THE TAX LIMITATION. MR
MAILING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS WE ARE TRULY
EXPERIENCING UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES WHILE THE CUPBOARD
PANDEMIC CONTINUES WITH NO END
IN SIGHT SO DOES CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
AND A LOOMING WILDFIRE SEASON I
AM PRESENTING A CA ELEVEN AS A
COMPROMISE REPLACEMENT MEASURE
TO THE MEASURE WHICH PREVIOUSLY
QUALIFY BUT NOW HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE NOVEMBER BALLOT. THE
CCA ELEVEN ENSURES THAT FUNDING
FOR FIRE PROTECTION A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ARE STRENGTHENED AND
PROTECTED IT ALLOWS FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN REFORM AND
FAIRNESS IN CALIFORNIA'S
PROPERTY TAX FORMULAS WHAT
LEAVING THE PROTECTIONS OF
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN INTACT
THIS MEASURE CONTAINS SEVERAL
PROVISIONS INTENDED TO INCREASE
THE STOCK OF AVAILABLE HOUSING.
AND PROVIDE PROTECTIONS TO
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS IN THE
HOUSING MARKET WHILE CREATING
PROTECTED REVENUE FOR
UNDERFUNDED FIRE DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ENSURING
THE COUNTIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECEIVE EQUITABLE
FUNDING PROPOSITIONS FIFTY
EIGHT AND ONE NINETY THREE
CREATED A MECHANISM FOR PARENTS
AND GRANDPARENTS TO TRANSFER
THEIR HOMES TO THEIR CHILDREN
OR GRANDCHILDREN WITHOUT THOSE
HOMES HAVING THEIR PROPERTY TAX
REASSESSED. HIS PER OF THOSE
PROPOSITIONS THESE EXCLUSIONS
HAVE BEEN ROUTINELY EXPLOITED
BY WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS AS A
TOOL FOR MANY TO WHAT A SECT OR
FOR ALMOST THAT FOR THE BEING
SET IT UP WORDS IN HERE THOSE
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY HOMES ALSO
INHERITING THE ARRAY TAX. LET
ME EMPHASIZE ACA ELEVEN WILL
PROTECT. BECAUSE WHEN FAMILIES
NUMBER IS GOING TO TREAT AT
PROPERTY AS A PRICE. RESIDENCE
IT WILL CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE FOR
VACATION HOMES AND OTHER USES
THAT TO NOT INCLUDE A PRIMARY
RESIDENCE AGAIN ACA ELEVEN
PROTECTS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS. OF PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS TO PASS THE FAMILY
HOME TO THEIR CHILDREN ENSURING
THAT THEIR HEIRS CAN AFFORD TO
MOVE INTO THAT HOME AS THEIR
PRIMARY. RESIDENCE BY CLOSING
THE LOOPHOLES ON ADDITIONAL
PROPERTIES PROSPECTIVELY THE
STATE WILL BE ABLE TO GENERATE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR FIRE PROTECTION EMERGENCY
SERVICES. CRITICAL LOCAL
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE
HOMELESS TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ARE TO HELP
FUND THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACROSS THE
STATE. AC ELEVEN WILL OPEN UP
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF NEW
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
RENTERS AND FIRST TIME HOME
OWNERS BY ALLOWING THOSE THAT
QUALIFY AND WOULD LIKE TO SELL
THEIR HOME BUT CANCER DUE TO
BEING UNABLE TO FOR THE
PROPERTY TAXES ON A NEW HOME.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AS A
RESULT OF INCREASED DEMAN A CA
ELEVEN WILL SPUR HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ALL INCOME LEVELS
TO ACCOMMODATE THE DEMAND FOR
HOUSING STATEWIDE. ACA LEVIN
CONTINUES TO PROTECT SENIORS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS OF WILDFIRE
BY LIMITING PROPERTY TAX
INCREASES ON PRIMARY RESIDENCES.
AC ELEVEN ALSO REMOVES UNFAIR
LOCATION RESTRICTIONS FROM
PROPOSITIONS SIXTY AND NINETY.
THUS ALLOWING THOSE THAT ARE
QUALIFIED TO MOVE TO ANYWHERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND RETAIN THEIR
BASE YOUR VALUE PROPERTY TAX
PORTABILITY. REMOVING THESE
RESTRICTIONS WILL ALLOW OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS TO
MOVE CLOSER TO FAMILY OR
MEDICAL CARE TO A SENIOR
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY ORTO
REPLACE A DAMAGED HOME ANYWHERE
IN CALIFORNIA. THE NEW FUNDING
GENERATED BY A CA ELEVEN WILL
PLAY A ROLE IN OUR STATES
ECONOMIC RECOVERY FROM THE COLD
WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC WITH
LONG TERM REVENUE ESTIMATE
ESTIMATED TO BE OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. ACA
ELEVEN DEDICATES TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY O
HISTORICALLY UNDERFUNDED FIRE
DISTRICTS IN BOTH RURAL AND
URBAN COMMUNITIES WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE RESPONSE
WHICH WILL HELP PROTECT
MILLIONS OF HOMES AND MILLIONS
OF LIVES. AND FINALLY THE
AMENDMENT PROVIDES LOCAL
REVENUE TO COUNTIES CITIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS BY GENERATING
STABLE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE FOR
EVERY COUNTY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AT A TIME WHEN COUNTY IS NEEDED
THE MOST. OF PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE A C. ELEVEN PROTECTS
COUNTIES AGAINST ANY POTENTIAL
REVENUE LOSS FROM THOSE THAT
MOVE TO ANOTHER COUNTY. BY
ESTABLISHING AN OFFSET FUND
WHICH WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE PROTECTION YEAR IN AND
YEAR OUT TO ENSURE LOCAL
GENERAL FUND STABILITY MEMBERS
LET US SUBMIT TO THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION THIS COMPROMISE
MEASURE WHICH IS A TWO HOUSE.
MULTI PARTY SOLUTION I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MIND MR COOLEY ARE YOU SEEKING
RECOGNITION REAR CHAMBER YES
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS. YOU KNOW
IS THERE ON THIS FLOOR WE TALK
ABOUT CERTAIN PHENOMENON THAT
WE SEE HAPPENING IN THE WORLD
WE GET CONCERNED ABOUT. WE
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
ECONOMY HAS CHANGED. EVERYONE
FACES MUCH MORE ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY IN THE WORLD TODAY.
PEOPLE OF MY GENERATION OF LOST
PENSIONS. WE ARE MORE RESEARCH
MORE AT RISK IN RETIREMENT WE
TALK ABOUT KIDS WHO ACTUALLY
WILL NOT EARN MORE THAN THEIR
PARENTS. SO MUCH MORE ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY AND COMPLEXITY IN
THE WORLD TODAY. THIS IS A
FREQUENT REFRAIN ON THIS BEFORE
WE TALK ABOUT ALL OF THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND I'M IS ALL
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES THERE IS
ONE TOOL. IN THE PARENTS TOOL
KIT. THAT IS SO SIMPLE. TO
IMPROVE THE LIFE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND THAT IS THE PROP
THIRTEEN THE THIS ABILITY TO
CONVEY YOUR- TAX BASIS IN YOUR
PROPERTY. TO YOUR KIDS. BY YEAH
AT THE TIME OF YOUR DEATH. IT
WAS FULLY WITHIN THE
CONTEMPLATION OF PROP. WHEN
THIS WAS ORIGINALLY PASSED I
REMEMBER THAT DEBATE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. ARM
BECAUSE IT COVERED THE WHOLE
MEN OTHER PROPERTY AFTER
MILLION DOLLARS SORT ALWAYS HAD
CONTEMPLATION MORE THAN ONE
PROPERTY. IT WAS A MECHANISM
PERMIT PARENTS. TO CONVEY
SOMETHING IN ON TO THEIR KIDS
AND I WOULD SAY THIS
FLEXIBILITY ESTABLISHED BY THIS
LONG CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
FEW TOOLS LEFT IN THE POPULAR
TOOL KIT. DID ANYBODY. WITH A
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION OR LESS.
CAN TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN
THIS MEASURE WILL BREAK THAT UP
BY IMPOSING THIS RESIDENCE
REQUIREMENT DON'T THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE. I ALSO NOTE THAT.
THEY'LL SAY BUT THEY CAN
EXERCISE IT. THERE OWNERSHIP
RIGHT WITHOUT PENALTY FOR A
YEAR. WELL WE'RE AND COLD IN
THERE SAYING THAT OUR ECONOMY
MAY NOT RECOVER FOR THREE YEARS
I THINK OF THE EXAMPLE OF MY
OWN FAMILY. MY PARENTS BOUGHT.
BOUGHT A WHOLE NINETEEN SEVENTY
ON THE MONTEREY PENINSULA MY
DAD DIED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. MY MOM DIED IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN. I'M THE
YOUNGEST OF FOUR BOYS. TWO OF
MY BROTHERS OWN HOMES ON THAT
SAME TOWN WAS A ROLE BIGGER
HOME. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE
INTO MY PARENTS HOME. I'M UP IN
SACRAMENTO I'M NOT MOVING INTO
MY PARENTS HOME. MY OLDEST
BROTHER IS A PASTOR IN CANADA
HE MOST ASSUREDLY IS NOT MOVING
AT ALL. BUT THAT WAS TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THAT WAS RIGHT
AT THE START. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST DOWNTURNS IN RECENT
DECADES. TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
ACTUALLY HERE IN CENTRAL COUNTY
WAS THE YEAR THAT I ORGANIZED.
WORKSHOPS IN ENGLISH SPANISH
AND RUSSIAN IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN TO HELP MY
RESIDENTS DIRECTOR OF A DEAL
WITH THE DOWNTURN. BUT IT TOOK
SEVERAL YEARS FOR PROPERTY
VALUES TO BE RECOUP SO A ONE
YEAR LIMITATION. WHAT A FORCED
US TO SELL THE PROPERTY IN A
DOWNTURN. WHICH IS ADVERSE TO
OUR INTERESTS I'M NOT SAYING
THERE ISN'T SOME POTENTIAL IN
THIS BUT I ACTUALLY FEEL IS NOT
DRAFT WITH A VIEW TO DO CERTAIN
TYPES OF FAMILIES. THE EASE OF
PASSING ON ECONOMIC VALUE TO
YOUR KIDS. AND IF YOU THINK
THAT THIS IS A DIFFERENT
POSITION I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU JUST HEARD. WE ARE GOING TO
ENABLE. FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
MOVES IN TRANSFER IN THE BASED
TAXATION FOR THE PARENTS. WE
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR FIRE
FIGHTING FOR CAL FIRE WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR UNDER FUNDER
FIRE AGENCIES AND IF PEOPLE
CHOOSE TO MOVE TO ONE OF THE
OTHER FIFTY SEVEN COUNTIES
WE'RE GOING TO BACK FILL THAT
COUNTY. WHERE THE HECK IS ALL
THAT MONEY COMING FROM. BUT
PERRY IN BACK THE ABILITY OF
PERRANCE TO GIVE IT ON TO THEIR
KIDS I DO WANT TO SAY THAT THE
FAMILY FARM PIECE I THINK IS
VERY ADANTAGEOUS. THE FAMILY
FARMS HAVE MANY OF MY DISTRICT
I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT IS
ADVANTAGEOUS. BUT THIS IS A
MAJOR HERE. UPON THE ABILITY OF
ANY PARENT IN CALIFORNIA. WHO
IN GOOD TIMES AND BAD AS
STRUGGLE TO HOLD ON TO THEIR
HOME. PAY THEIR BILLS KNOWING
THAT IT CAN GO TO THEIR KIDS.
IT'S A MAJOR RE DOING OF AN
IRAQI IS VERY BASIC
EXPECTATIONS Y. URGENT OFF A
NOBLE. THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY
MYSTERY MAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF A CA ELEVEN FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO AGREE- COMPLETELY WITH
MY OF VARIOUS TEAM MEMBER FROM
RANCHO CORDOVA AND THAT THIS IS
A VERY RELIABLE WAY. FOR
PARENTS TO PASS ASSETS ON TO
THEIR CHILDREN IN FACT IT'S SO
RELIABLE BUT THIS HAS BEEN A
GREAT HELP. IN PROTECTING AND
CONSOLIDATING WEALTH IN
CALIFORNIA. AND MAKING SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN BORN
INTO A FAMILY THAT OWNS
PROPERTY. NOT ONLY ARE THEY
GOING TO NOW IN HER AT THAT
PROPERTY BUT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO HAVE TO PAY ANYTHING FOR
THAT PRIVILEGE THEY WON'T HAVE
TO PAY ANYTHING. IN TAXES TO
HELP SUPPORT THEIR COMMUNITIES
NOW IF YOU ARE THE PERSON THAT
HE MENTIONED WHO WORKS HARD
THEIR WHOLE LIFE AND STRUGGLES.
AND SUCCEEDS AND CAN PURCHASE
THAT SAME PROPERTY YOU NOT ONLY
HAVE TO PAY YOUR SHARE OF TAXES
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO PAY THAT
SHARE OF TAXES FOR THAT LUCKY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS BORN INTO
THAT. PRIVILEGE AND THAT WEALTH
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO PAY FOR
THAT PORTION TO SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO PAY FOR AND NOT BECAUSE THEY
BURNED IT. BUT BECAUSE THEY
WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO BE BORN
INTO A FAMILY THAT ALREADY HAD
IT. OUT INHERITING A HOUSE THAT
YOUR PARENTS OWN TONIGHT YOU
GREW UP IN AND YOU'RE GOING TO
MOVE INTO IS EXEMPT. FROM THIS
LEGISLATION. YOU CAN DO THAT
AND MAINTAIN THAT PROPERTY BASE
THAT YOU WON'T HAVE TO SELL
THAT FAMILY HOUSE. BUT MY
GOODNESS IF I HAVE BEEN LUCKY
ENOUGH TO BEEN BORN INTO A
FAMILY WHICH I WASN'T. THAT WAS
GOING TO PASS ME A COUPLE OF
STRIP MALLS. I'M A SHOPPING
MALL SOME GAS STATIONS A COUPLE
DRY CLEANERS. I'D ALREADY BE
THRILLED. AND YOU KNOW WHAT I'D
BE HAPPY TO PAY MY PORTION INTO
MY COMMUNITY. AND HELP FLATTEN
THAT BASE THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO
WHO ARE ABLE TO PURCHASE THAT
BECAUSE THEY SUCCEED ON THEIR
OWN. MAYBE BRING THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES DOWN A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE PAYING THE
FULL BURDEN OF WHAT THAT
WEALTHY PERSON IS NOT PAYING.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WEALTH HAS CONSOLIDATED IN THE
STATE WHY THE RICH ARE GETTING
RICHER AND WHY THE POOR ARE
GETTING POORER. WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO HELP
FLATTEN THAT OUT A LITTLE BIT
WE'RE NOT TAKING ANYONE'S
PROPERTY AWAY WE'RE NOT
STOPPING THEM FROM AND HEARD.
FROM THAT PROPERTY BUT THEY
SHOULD BE PAYING AT LEAST THEIR
FAIR SHARE. AND RIGHT NOW THEY
ARE NOT PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE
AYE URGENT A YES VOTE ON A C.
ELEVEN. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
SEEING NO FURTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING ECOGNITION MISTER
MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IN PARTICULAR THE MAJORITY
LEADER IN THE SENATE FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND PULLING- THE
PARTIES TOGETHER FOR THIS
COMPROMISE IN THE INTEREST OF
ALL THOSE PARTIES AND AGAIN FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
VOTERS. IN CALIFORNIA TO THE
LEADERS OF OUR RESPECTIVE
HOUSES FOR THEIR COLLABORATION
ON THIS MEASURE IN SUMMARY ACA
LEVEL ADDED THE AVAILABLE
HOUSING STOCK IN ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CHALLENGES A CA ELEVEN
WILL HELP FIND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THROUGH GREATER TAX
FAIRNESS IN A SEA LEVEL BETTER
PROTECT LIVES AND PROPERTY FROM
WILDFIRES LET US NOT FORGET
THAT THIS THREAT THAT WILL BE
WITH US FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE FOR THOSE REASONS MANY
MORE LET UP RATIFY THIS
COMPROMISE AND SUBMIT TO THE
VOTERS A CA ELEVEN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL FLOWS THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
SIX KNOWS TO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MA'AM
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY TWO I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO PRINT A
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL RELATIVE
TO SB NINETY EIGHT. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE CLERK WILL NOTE
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
TWO I'VE MOVED TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO PRINT A
LETTER IN THE JOURNAL RELATIVE
TO A. B. SEVENTY EIGHT. MR
FLORA. WE OBJECT TO THAT BUT
THAT'S ROLL CALL MISTER
CALDERON MOVES TO MISTER BONTA
SECONDS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRED BOTH THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY TO VOTE THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED I HEARD ABOUT THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. YOUR WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE EYES FIFTY THREE NINE
KNOWS FIFTEEN THE MOTION IS
ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. OKAY SYNONYMS
CONSENT TO RETURN ITEM NINE A.
B. EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION BUDGET
TO THE SENATE. THAT OBJECTION
SUCH AS- MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS IF I CAN
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION. DOCTOR
CHOICE THE FATHER PASSED AWAY
LAST FRIDAY- NAME CHOI WAS
BURIED ON. MOTHER MOTHER PASSED
AWAY LAST FRIDAY AND I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR CONDOLENCES ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSE. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED ANDWE WILL NOW
MOVE FOR PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
TAKE YOUR SEATS THIRTY YOUR
TIME OFF THE FLOOR. YEAH. ONE
ADDITIONAL ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
DESK WILL BE HELD OPEN TO
RECEIVE SENATE MESSAGES.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
THERE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON IN IN
GERMANY MEMORY. MISTER DAVID
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT THE
FRONT OF THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
GERMANY MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. ON BEHALF OF MY CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN OUR SAN
FRANCISCO DELEGATION. IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY. IN THE
MEMORY OF HARRY BRIDGE. FORMER
SUPERVISOR SAN FRANCISCO A
LIFELONG LGBT Q. RIGHTS
ACTIVIST. WHO PASSED AWAY THIS
WEEK. LIKE SO MANY OF HIS PEERS
HERBERT FOUND HIS POLITICAL
VOICE EMITS THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AS A METHODIST
MINISTER IN CHICAGO. AFTER
MOVING TO SAN FRANCISCO HE
LATER BECAME DEEPLY INVOLVED.
IN PROGRESSIVE POLITICS AS
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
GAY GAY DEMOCRATIC CLUB. THIS
LED HARRY TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE GAY RIGHTS PIONEER HARVEY
MILK. BEFORE HER REMOTE WAS
ASSASSINATED MILK MADE A
RECORDING ASKING THAT. SHOULD
ANYTHING HAPPEN TO HIM HARRY
BRIT BE NAMED THE SUCCESSOR ON
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. AFTER
MILKS TRAGIC ASSASSINATION IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. RICK
WAS FORMALLY APPOINTED TO
SUCCEED HIM ON THE BOARD. AS
THE FORMER MAYOR WHO APPOINTED
BRIT SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN
RECENTLY REMARKED HARRY WAS
PROGRESSIVE BEFORE THE WORD
BECAME VOTE. IN THE EARLY PARTS
OF HIS ELECTED CAREER. IT WAS
THE ONLY OPENLY GAY ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN SAN FRANCISCO ONE
OF THE VERY FEW IN OUR COUNTRY.
ALONG WITH MEDICAL FROM THE
ACLU. HARRY CREATED THE IDEA TO
GIVE TO GIVE RIGHTS TO ALL THE
BEAUTY Q. COUPLES WHO WERE
DENIED THE RIGHT TO MARRY AT
THE TIME. HE AUTHORED OUR
NATION'S FIRST COMPREHENSIVE.
DOMESTIC PARTNER LEGISLATION.
AFTER BUILDING COALITIONS WITH
CHINESE AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
LEADERS IN OUR CITY. HE FOUGHT
AGAINST THE AIDS EPIDEMIC HE
CHAMPION RENT CONTROL HE
ADVOCATED TIRELESSLY FOR
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT OF THE
POLICE. THESE ARE ISSUES THE
REMAIN PRESSING TO THIS DAY.
HARRY BREAKTHROUGH EMBODIED THE
BOLD PROGRESSIVE VALUES OF SAN
FRANCISCO. HE IS SURVIVED BY
ONE BROTHER HIS CLOSE FRIENDS
AND CARE GIVERS INCLUDING HIS
FORMER AIDE SHARON JOHNSON HIS
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF RICK
REBELLO AND TIM OFFERED WHO
SERVED AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION. COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN EXTENDING OUR
DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO HIS LOVED
ONES. IN A TIME OF PROTEST IN
THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HONOR THOSE
PIONEERS OF OUR STATE. WHO
FIRST FOUGHT FOR EQUALITY FOR
ALL I JUST RETURNED TODAY IN
THE MEMORY. OF JERRY BROWN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATH BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUESTS TO
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
HELLO MR KING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE SEVERE MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN THE
WORDS OF FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOMOMI ITANO HARY BRENT WAS A
MAN. OF GREAT HUMILITY WHO
CHAMPIONED COUNTLESS SOCIAL
CAUSES INSPIRED SO MANY LGBTQ
LEADERS AND THEIR ALLIES. HE
DID NOT SEEK THE LIMELIGHT BOOK
WHEN CALLS THE SERVICE BY THEN
BEAR DIANNE FEINSTEIN. WHO
CHOSE HIM TO FILL THE SHOES OF
DEMANDED A PROGRESSIVE LEADER
TO SERVE OUT THE TERM. FOR MANY
YEARS HE WAS THE LONE RELIABLE
PROGRESSIVE VOTE ON THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. BUT HE WORKED
HARD TO BUILD A LINES ACROSS
THE WHOLE COMMUNITIES. AS THE
LGBT COMMUNITY START TO GAIN
POWER AT THE BALLOT BOX
PROPELLING CAROL MEGAN RIVER
AFTER BURKE TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. IN TOWN ON THE
ROAD TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOL BOARD HARRY STRONGLY.
ASSERT IMPORTS OF BUILDING
ALLIES AMONGST PEOPLE COLOR THE
ELEVATED ASIAN AND AFRICAN
AMERICAN LEADERS. ALONG SIDE OF.
HARRY WORK WITH THOSE SAME
LEADERS TO ENACT PROJECT TEN A
PROGRAM FOR LESBIAN GAY
BISEXUAL YOUTH IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS. LED
THE FIGHT FOR INCREASED
RESOURCES DURING THE AIDS
PANDEMIC. IT'S AN HONOR FOR ME
TO JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRUE IN
MOURNING THE LOSS OF AN
INCREDIBLE LEADERS SAN
FRANCISCO NOT JUST. FOR THE
LGBT COMMUNITY BUT FOR OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED FOR SUMMER RECESS
PURSUANT TO THE JOINT RULES
UNTIL MONDAY JULY THIRTEENTH AT
ONE PM OR UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER THE DESPERATE OPEN
PROCESS ANY MESSAGES. WE'RE NOT
IN. MR TING MOVE THE MISTER
BONTA SECOND THIS ADVANTAGE AND.